Hey Kian!
Hey Hendrik!
Du, wir haben ja schon 45 Folgen akronomisierbar jetzt weg, ne?
Aber ich finde, wir müssen unbedingt jetzt die 46. machen, weil 45 ist so eine negative Zahl.
Warum das?
Na, die 45 wird doch demnächst impeached.
Ah, OMG, ja, da ist der Joke.
Und weil 46 so was Positives sein muss, haben wir uns noch jemand Neues mit an Bord geholt.
Deswegen haben wir dieses Mal einen richtig geilen Gast.
Darf ich vorstellen? Der Tom. Hi Tom, grüß dich.
Hi Henrik, hi Kilian, hallöchen.
Hi.
Das ist auch gar keine Erwartungshaltung, die hier aufgebaut wurde.
Ich liebe ja Folgen mit Gästen.
Und auch diesmal hat der Gast wieder eine ganz besondere Geschichte mit.
Aber darauf können wir vielleicht, wollen wir darauf gleich oder später eingehen?
Ich glaube, dann machen wir das dann nachher gleich.
Es ist ja so, das ist das Hauptthema der Folge dann.
Aber wie du gerade schon sagst, ich glaube, man kann wirklich mit Abstand sagen,
dass unsere Folgen mit Gästen mit Abstand die besten sind.
Und erst danach kommt unser gemeinsames Zweierzgeschwafel.
Aber da gehen wir dafür dann richtig in die Tiefe.
In die Tiefe, ja, genau.
Man sieht die Airquotes hier gerade nicht.
Nee, wollen wir eine kurze News-Section machen?
Das ist ja irgendwie...
Ich habe gestern irgendwie bis kurz nach drei
irgendwie gedoomscrollt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch war.
Ja, wir leben in besonderen Zeiten aktuell.
Ich versuche es zu vermeiden in der letzten Zeit.
Kann ich gut nachvollziehen.
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass Twitter jetzt in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
wesentlich leerer werden wird.
Ich habe mindestens...
Naja, jetzt wo hier Mr. Chaos aus Twitter rausgeschmissen wurde,
werden wahrscheinlich seine ganzen Deppen ihm folgen
und zu irgendwelchen anderen esoterischen Telegram-Verschwörungs-Messengeren gehen.
Aber glaubst du wirklich, was genau für eine Plattform das ist?
Telegram hat ja schon den Ruf immer gehabt für die ganzen Covidioten,
auch hierzulande und Reichsbürgerspinner.
Aber ich glaube, die hatten auch in letzter Zeit ein bisschen Probleme damit
und wollten da wieder weg, weil da auch Dinge geröscht wurden.
Und sind mittlerweile alle zu dieser tollen Plattform
und haben ins Parler gegangen,
die aber, ich glaube, gestern noch von Google
schon aus dem Play Store geschmissen wurde,
weil die nicht moderieren.
Und Apple hat dann auch gedroht,
wenn die keine Moderations-Tools einführen,
was bei Apple halt auch Guidelines,
die kennen mich ja bei Google nicht aus.
Du musst halt, wenn User-Generated-Content da ist,
die Möglichkeit haben, das zu reporten.
Und das muss auch irgendwie moderiert werden,
wenn Dinge reportet werden.
Und Apple hat gesagt, wenn ihr das nicht macht,
dann seid ihr auch aus dem App Store raus.
Ich habe das gehört, alle sagen,
ich gehe jetzt zu Parler. Ich denke immer,
das spricht sich wahrscheinlich Parler aus.
Ah, welchen Y-Mann wäre das?
Ich würde dazu gesprochen, aber sonst keine Ahnung.
Das Infinitiv im Französischen ist mit
ER hinten. Ich glaube, das wäre sogar
korrekt das französische Wort.
Aber frag mich nicht nach meinem Französisch.
Aber zumindest alle haben so gesagt, ich gehe jetzt zu Parler
und Apple und Google so.
Ich glaube, wir schmeißen mal Parler raus aus
unseren Stores. Ja, das hat das Schöne daran,
wenn diese Plattformen verschwindet. Ich meine, gut, das Web
existiert immer als Möglichkeit. Das wirst du auch
mobilgerätig überfinden. Ist das das Schöne?
Ist das schön?
Ja, natürlich.
Das Schöne daran ist, dass du halt diesen Leuten keine Plattform bieten musst.
Und wenn die sich da weiterziehen und du nimmst denen halt eine Plattform nach der anderen weg,
die können nicht mehr auf Facebook, oh, wie traurig, die können nicht mehr auf Twitter,
die können nicht mehr auf Twitch streamen, die können nicht mehr auf Shopify verkaufen,
die können nicht mehr Spenden sammeln und sonst wo, die können sich nicht mehr unterhalten
über native Apps an der Stelle, dann nimmst du denen halt immer wieder ein bisschen den Wind aus den Segeln.
Natürlich hast du dieses Problem, dass du diese
World Gardens hast und die halt auch irgendwie moderiert werden
und da Leute sagen können.
Meinst du, dieses internationale Spinnertum ist nur
deshalb so schlimm geworden, weil die Leute plötzlich auch
das Internet für sich entdeckt haben, die normalerweise
so in ihrer Kneipe bloß rumgehatet hätten
und jetzt plötzlich irgendwie auf
Messageboards rumhaten können und eine Echo-Chamber
haben, die sie vorher nicht hatten?
Ja, vor allem die großen öffentlichen Echo-Chambers.
Wenn die sich auf irgendwelchen Messageboards
rumhaten, das gab es ja schon seitdem, das Internet
existiert, aber gut, nicht alle sind technisch
versiert genug, um das zu machen. Aber dass
gerade halt an sonst wie alle Leute da draußen publishen kannst,
indem du deine Verschwörungstheorien auf Facebook postest
oder ganz öffentlich auf Twitter, da geht halt einiges.
Natürlich verbreitet sich das umso mehr, umso besser.
Tom, du musst uns einfach unterbrechen, sonst funktioniert das nicht.
Gar kein Problem.
Also ich glaube auch tatsächlich,
dass die Einfachheit der Reichweiten-Generation
in den letzten Jahren irgendwie dazu geführt hat,
dass diese Phänomene so groß und so stark wurden.
Ich habe erst heute im Daily Podcast von der New York Times gehört,
dass es in wenigen Tagen vor dem Sturm aufs Kapitol, in Airquotes,
eine neue Facebook-Gruppe gab, die wohl innerhalb von zwei Tagen 200.000 Mitglieder generiert hat
und in der es speziell darum ging, diesen Tag und alle Aktionen dort zu planen.
Facebook hat eine Weile gebraucht, um dann irgendwie diese Gruppe dann wieder zu löschen und dann war quasi so eine kritische Masse schon erzeugt, die dann auch wieder auf andere Kanäle ausgewichen ist. Das war dann halt nicht mehr so groß, aber die Community war schon ins Leben gerufen sozusagen für diesen Anlass.
Deswegen, ich weiß auch, ich bin auch sehr gespannt, wie das jetzt weitergeht.
Im besten Falle ist es wirklich so, dass durch dieses Blocking, durch das Löschen der Gruppen,
durch diese Plattformen, die endlich mal geführt ein bisschen Rückgrat zeigen,
diesen Bewegungen so der Wind aus den Segeln genommen wird, dass sich das alles ein bisschen beruhigt.
Im Worst Case habe ich auch ein bisschen Angst, dass es zu mehr Radikalisierung führt.
Ich würde gerade sagen, ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass die, wenn die sich dann auf,
dass sie sich parallel zurückziehen
und dann
dort in einer
noch härteren Bubble
sind. Das ist ja wirklich niemand mehr,
der widerspricht.
Bei Facebook und Twitter, da haben sie wenigstens irgendwie noch
die Schimpfe der normalen
Gesellschaft unten drunter
und ein bisschen Konversation. Aber wenn sich
die Leute, die sich radikalisiert haben
und dann aus den normalen Mainstreet-Plattformen
rausgeschmissen werden, dann in ihre eigene Plattform
zurückziehen, dann ist der da wirklich
komplette Echo Chamber.
dann ist da wirklich überhaupt keine Konversation
mehr. Das hat die auf Facebook vorher
auch schon, das ändert sich meiner Meinung nach nicht
viel an Status Quo.
Die haben sich auch
in Gruppen zurückgezogen und komplett
untereinander da unterhalten und du hast
dein Bullshit auch in die Familienkreise
breitgetragen, aber Facebook war halt das Netzwerk
für Familien und nicht das komplett
öffentliche. Du meinst, weil
die Social Grafen bei Facebook
eh schon so in sich geschlossen waren, dass da...
Ja genau, du hast immer auf Facebook bist du halt
nicht für komplett öffentlichen Kram, es sei denn, du ziehst dich
in die Gruppen zurück, in die
du eh dann deine Gruppendynamik hast.
Und auch auf Twitter
tweetst du halt wirklich quasi
an die Öffentlichkeit, es sei denn, du hast ein Protected Account,
wo das halt wirklich
jeder lesen kann und jede damit
interagieren kann. Aber
natürlich tun das auch die wenigsten und ich weiß nicht, inwiefern
man sich da überhaupt dein Verhalten anpasst, wenn man
da irgendwelchen rechten Bullshit raushaut und dann
zwei Leute drunter schreiben, du Spinner,
dann ändert das überhaupt
was, ich weiß es nicht.
Tja, das weiß ich halt nicht. Ich hatte
immer, ich hatte halt immer gehofft, dass man
wenigstens ein bisschen, wenn man
den Leuten wenigstens ein bisschen die Stirn bietet
und sagt, das stimmt so nicht oder ein bisschen
ein Gespräch anfängt,
wo man den Thesen widerspricht
und nicht das einfach so
stehen lässt, dass es dann eventuell einen positiven
Effekt hat.
Aber auf jeden Fall hat es ja jetzt
dazu geführt, dass
Mr. Racist
in Chief oder Terrorist in Chief
keine Ahnung, was da die beste aktuelle
Bezeichnung ist. Der Mann mit den
Atomcodes. Ja, in netter Weise
hat er dann Nancy Pelosi gemeint,
es gibt Maßnahmen, dass er
nicht nutzen kann direkt.
Also die Frage hin, ob er denn die Macht
dazu hätte. Also anscheinend
gibt es da irgendwelche Maßnahmen in place,
um ihn daran zu hindern, wenn er denn
wollte, die Nuklearcodes zu benutzen.
Ich meine, wie das genau technisch funktioniert,
keine Ahnung.
One-Password-Einladung.
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
wahrscheinlich
ich habe ja gehört, ihm ist zweimal
der Twitter-Account aufgemacht
ihm ist zweimal der Twitter-Account
aufgemacht worden von unterschiedlichen Leuten
weil sein Passwort jedes Mal mega
2020 war
wie bestätigt
ist das eigentlich, davon gehört habe ich ja auch
ich weiß nicht, ob es zweimal war
das letzte habe ich wirklich nicht geglaubt
weil das zu absurd klang, aber da gab es wirklich
einen ganzen Newsartikel, dass es wirklich bestätigt war
und dass es kein Fake war
ich glaube es immer noch nicht, aber das wirkt einfach so absurd,
dass Twitter da keine Maßnahmen in Place hat, um den Account des Präsidenten,
der ja doch irgendwie ein bisschen, ich will nicht sagen in Macht in Anführungsstrichen,
aber du hast auf jeden Fall die Möglichkeit, sehr viele Leute gleichzeitig auf der Plattform zu adressieren
und durch die falschen Sachen, die du da postest, als ein potenzieller Hacker,
könntest du halt wirklich Gewalt in Seiten, gut, das macht er selber auch schon,
aber du könntest hier quasi einen Krieg mit Iran theoretisch lostreten auf Twitter,
wie es Trump ja probiert hat.
möglich ist das durch die falschen Sachen, die du da raushaust.
Aber dass es halt
nicht anderweitig geschützt ist durch Twitter selber,
dass die nicht irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, das wirkt so bescheuert,
wenn die einfach Mager 20 als Passwort
drinstecken.
Also was ich ja lustig finde, ist die
schiere Anzahl von Fake-Accounts, die jetzt auftaucht,
wo Leute irgendwie so tun, wie
ich hab mir jetzt mal einen neuen Account geklickt.
Das letzte, was ich gerade eben erst gesehen hab, war
von so einem Boris Johnson MP
Fake-Account, der plötzlich als Name
und Bild Donald J. Trump heißt,
der erste Tweet ist, thanks to my friend Boris Johnson
for letting me use his Twitter-Account.
Gestern hatten sie ja noch das Problem,
dass dieser zweite Account, Ed POTUS,
dieser Funktions-Account, der ja noch funktioniert,
und da hat er einen direkten Rant losgelassen,
haben wir mit Hendrik ja gestern noch unterhalten,
wo er dann direkt einen fetten Thread losgelassen hat,
von wegen hier Twitter will Free Speech suppressen,
aber da werden wir was gegen tun,
der Thread war innerhalb von ein paar Minuten schon wieder weg.
Ich hatte noch so spekuliert,
Eigentlich könnte er ja jetzt POTUS benutzen und Kilian so, naja, guck mal, hier hat er was geschrieben und ich so, nee, den Tweet kann ich schon nicht mehr lesen.
Da war er schon wieder weg.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob sie den Account gesperrt haben, weil er von der Person benutzt wurde und die Person darf nicht mehr oder ob sie das wegen dieses Tweets gesperrt hatten.
Das wäre immer noch spannend rauszufinden.
Zumindest gab es auch noch lustige Geschichten am Rande, die ich noch erwähnenswert fand.
Ich habe da mal einen Link in die Shownotes gepackt.
Unser werter Freund der Show, der Trolli Schmidlauch,
hat sich einen schönen Stunt geleistet.
Und zwar war einer von den letzten Tweets vom Präsidofen
vor ein paar Tagen markiert worden von Twitter mit
Hierauf kann nicht mehr geantwortet werden.
Es darf nicht retweetet werden.
Es darf nicht geliked werden.
Und der Herr Schmidlauch hat es tatsächlich geschafft,
da irgendwie unten drunter Test zu antworten.
Da war exakt eine Antwort drunter.
Und die hieß dann Test. Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, Mensch, der Junge hat echt Mut.
Aber lustige Aktion.
Hat er gesagt, wie ist denn die? Wenn Twitter gesagt hat, das geht nicht, dann haben die das Feature anscheinend doch nicht disabled?
Oder warst du da kaputt gegangen?
Wir haben dann, glaube ich, in einem Tweet geschrieben, er hat kurz beschrieben, wie er es gemacht hat.
Ich habe es mir jetzt nicht direkt gemerkt, aber ich gehe einfach fest davon aus, dass die einfach nicht alle APIs zum Tweeten zugemacht haben.
Und du siehst diese Antwort auch nicht.
Du siehst diese Antwort auch nicht direkt unter dem Tweet von Donald Trump,
sondern er hat
seine Antwort retweetet
und man sieht, dass es eine Antwort auf diesen Tweet ist.
Es ist nicht ganz, es ist,
irgendwie ist Twitter verschoben.
Das ist, da gibt es irgendwie
Dangling-Tweets, die
nicht ganz auflösen.
Zumindest, es bleibt spannend.
Ist das der Sendungstitel?
Dangling-Tweets, habt ihr sowas?
Na, eigentlich,
haben wir ja mit dir ein konkretes Thema
und ich würde das, glaube ich, zum Sendungstitel machen,
damit wir das so ein bisschen in den Vordergrund rücken.
Ich glaube, wir können jetzt auch langsam von den Nachrichten weg.
Das wird wahrscheinlich, diese Sektion wird wahrscheinlich eh nicht so gut altern.
Und wenn ich die Folge dann released habe, werden sich alle denken,
ach bist du noch, als Twitter noch lief oder irgend sowas,
bevor es das komplett ausgemacht haben werden.
Wir sind ja am 9. Januar aktuell. Mal schauen, wie das da noch weitergeht.
Ja, genau. Ich höre ja so einen Politik-Podcast und da kommt am Anfang immer
this show is recorded
on January
9th, 17, also diese
Folge ist aufgenommen am 9. Januar um
17.30 Uhr.
Things may have changed by the time you hear this.
So 10 Minuten später.
Keine Ahnung.
Naja, ist ja tatsächlich da
vorgestern, das ist ja tatsächlich so gewesen,
da hieß es noch, ja, wir reden jetzt mal
über die Wahl in Georgia.
Und ach nee, übrigens, wir haben gerade einen wütenden
Mob und dann nochmal, die haben
glaube ich an dem Tag drei Folgen gemacht und dann
irgendwie die eine noch ganz spät
nachts, als die Leute dann wieder raus waren und die tatsächlich
dann diese
Wahlegebnis Beglaubigung
dann zu Ende durchgezogen haben.
Das fand ich auch einen ziemlich geilen Akt. Die sind auch wie mit
den Stimmen da raus
und sind später
einfach wieder zurückgekommen und haben gesagt, leck mich am Arsch,
wer mit Zines jetzt durch?
Auf jeden Fall.
So, wirklich richtig absurd,
als ob die wirklich nichts geschafft haben.
Aber die Leute, die sind ja reingestirnt
und dann wussten die auch nicht mehr, was sie tun sollten.
Dann haben sie Telefone benutzt und Fotos gemacht und gepostet.
Und ihre Gesichter an Kameras gehalten und ihre Namen laut gesagt.
Also es gibt schon die ersten Mugshots von Leuten,
die vom FBI zu Hause abgeholt wurden.
Das ist so unglaublich dumm.
Vor allem, wenn die wenigstens dank Coronavirus
mit Masken rumgelaufen werden, dann hätte man die doch nicht erkannt.
Aber nee, die müssen natürlich ihre White Privilege bis zum Gehtnichtmehr leben
und ihre Gesichter in die Kameras halten.
auch noch sagen, wer sie sind in irgendwelchen Interviews,
wo sie herkommen.
Da kann ja nichts passieren, ich bin ja weiß.
Ich bin gemäßt worden, so eine Ungerechtigkeit.
Es gab auch schöne Videos von Leuten,
die auf Black Lives Matter
Demo waren oder sowas, die auch gesagt haben,
you are white people, you don't know how to crime,
you don't wear a mask, you say your name into a camera.
It's just, don't get me started.
Es ist halt
wirklich Privilege, du denkst, dass alles passiert,
weil halt auch nichts passiert.
Und schön, dass jetzt ein paar Leute wenig verhaftet werden
und ich hoffe, das geht wirklich weiter.
Mal schauen.
Gut, lass uns mal das Thema wechseln.
Ja.
Hi Tom.
Hi Kilian. Hi Hendrik.
Wir haben uns eigentlich besonders
auf den Teil der Sendung
gefreut, nicht auf den Nachrichtenteil am Anfang,
den wir normalerweise eigentlich nicht haben,
aber das war jetzt so viel Twitter-Relation,
dass wir das doch ein bisschen erwähnt haben.
Du bist
Teil,
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht genau,
was deine Involvierung
in das Projekt ist, aber du wirst uns das
nicht gleich erzählen, aber ich würde sagen einfach mal, du bist Teil
einer
Plattform für Menschen
oder
einer Organisation, die
Leuten eine Plattform bieten möchte,
die momentan eine
besondere Relevantnis hat, und zwar ist
das
Quarantänehelden.org, beziehungsweise
Quarantäneheldinnen.org.
Was ist denn das?
Quarantäne-Heldinnen.org ist eine Plattform, auf der Menschen, die entweder zu Risikogruppen gehören oder die gerade selber in Quarantäne sind, weil sie Corona-positiv sind oder Kontakt zu positiv getesteten Menschen hatten und die Hilfe benötigen.
die Hilfe benötigen beim Einkaufen oder die Botengänge nicht erledigen können, die vielleicht Arzneimittel brauchen oder die auch einfach Haustiere haben, die irgendwie mal um den Block Gassi geführt werden müssen.
Und wir haben gedacht, da muss es eine einfachere Möglichkeit geben, da Hilfe zu organisieren als Facebook. Und das war schon so der Startgedanke der Plattform.
Das ist ja so ein Ding, was ich immer mal wieder so als Projektidee höre. Wir brauchen eine Plattform für Leute, damit die sich untereinander finden und irgendwas gemeinsam machen können.
Dass sie sich gemeinsam kochen oder gemeinsam Musik machen oder sich gegenseitig in der Nachbarschaft helfen. Und an vielen Stellen läuft es dann immer auf sowas wie Facebook hinaus, weil da der soziale Graf einmal da ist. Oder auf sowas wie, was gibt es denn noch? Es gibt noch so lokale, nebenan die Ehe.
Genau.
Ist ganz groß, genau.
Und das waren auch damals, also ich war im Gründungsteam, sage ich mal, als die Idee geboren wurde, Anfang März war ich nicht involviert.
Das waren drei Freundinnen von mir aus München, die, ich glaube, da am Donnerstagabend in der WG-Küche saßen und irgendwie sich gesagt haben,
was macht eigentlich jetzt meine Oma, wenn sie irgendwie einkaufen muss?
Und gerade am Anfang des ersten Lockdowns waren wir alle sehr ängstlich. Niemand wusste, wie gefährlich ist es jetzt eigentlich überhaupt rauszugehen und so. Als alle das noch ernst genommen haben. Als alle das noch ernst genommen haben, ja. Und als alle noch irgendwie sich alle zehn Sekunden die Hände desinfiziert haben, nachdem sie irgendwie eine Türklinkke anzupassen haben.
Fasst ihr nicht ins Gesicht? Tom, fasst ihr nicht ins Gesicht?
Und dann war es, was macht die Oma jetzt? Und damals war es aber schon so eine Sache, dass man so gesagt hat, ja, man muss irgendwie sich im Kiez in der Nachbarschaft unterstützen. Und dann war aber auch so der Gedanke, okay, um sowas zu organisieren, die Plattformen, die es gibt, Facebook oder nebenan.de, die sind irgendwie uns nicht niederschwellig genug.
Einerseits, weil es natürlich eine große Gruppe von Menschen gibt, die zur Risikogruppe gehören und von denen wir so gedacht haben, die sind dann vielleicht nicht so affin. Und andererseits haben wir gesagt, beide Plattformen, zumindest last time we checked, haben ein Businessmodell, das auf Werbung beruht und damit auch so ein bisschen auf den Daten ihrer User.
Ja, deswegen haben wir gedacht, mit so einer einfachen, mit einem einfachen schwarzen Brett und einer E-Mail-Adresse und ohne Datensammlung muss das doch auch gehen. Und so war die Idee geboren und dann ging es in den ersten Wochen ganz schnell.
Was meinst du mit ganz schnell? Ihr habt dann relativ schnell eine Plattform zusammengebaut, irgendwie so ein ganz einfaches CMS, wo man Hilfe suchen und bieten kann quasi?
Genau, also der erste Proof of Concept war irgendwie, ich glaube, 24 Stunden später online. Die Basis im Backend war Firebase und im Frontend React. Die Jungs und Mädels, die das entwickelt haben, die hatten mit beiden Technologien schon Erfahrung, haben gesagt, wir klicken das mal zusammen.
Und dann waren auch relativ schnell die ersten Inserate drauf, Leute haben sich registriert und dann hatten wir damals tatsächlich das Glück, dass so ziemlich alle Medien, öffentlich-rechtliche Medien, lokal, überregional, alle hatten das große Bedürfnis, über positive Dinge zu berichten.
Die Nachrichten waren voll von Lockdown, alles bricht zusammen, Angst, aber es war so ein großes Bedürfnis da auch irgendwie zu zeigen, dass man trotzdem, dass es auch positive Geschichten gibt, dass sich Dinge zum Positiven verändern, dass Sachen entstehen und das hat uns damals wirklich sehr viel Support und Unterstützung gebracht, weil wir wirklich, ich glaube, innerhalb von drei oder vier Wochen hatten wir dann 38.000 registrierte Helder.
HelferInnen, also die Plattform bietet dir einerseits die Möglichkeit,
Genau, was macht die Plattform überhaupt?
Genau.
Du kannst, wenn du auf die Plattform kommst, dann wirst du im Prinzip gefragt,
bist du jetzt jemand, der gerade Hilfe sucht oder möchtest du gern helfen?
Wenn du Hilfe suchst, dann erstellst du ein kleines Inserat mit entweder deiner E-Mail-Adresse
oder mittlerweile auch über unsere Hotline und dann gibst du da deine Postbeitzahl ein.
Ja, das ist ein großes Thema, da können wir auch später noch drüber sprechen.
Und das basiert quasi nur, oder unser Matching basiert nur auf der Postleitzahl, weil wir gesagt haben, das reicht einfach aus.
Wir wollen ja keine Adressen oder irgendwas, personenbezogene Daten, das ist alles nicht so cool.
Und auf der anderen Seite, wenn du das siehst, diese Website, und du sagst, du bist jung, du bist fit, du möchtest gerne Leute unterstützen, kannst du quasi Notifications registrieren für deine Postleitzahl oder für verschiedene Postleitzahlenbereiche und bekommst dann eine Benachrichtigung, wenn jemand in deiner Postleitzahl Hilfe sucht.
Ja, cool.
Klingt echt cool, die Postleitzahl zu ketten.
Das ist echt clever.
Das ist angenehm niederschwellig, wie du schon meinst.
Und auch privatsphäre-technisch super.
Das finde ich echt eine clevere Idee.
Also es ist an manchen Stellen ein bisschen tricky,
weil obwohl es in Deutschland wirklich sehr viele Postleitzahlen gibt,
ist genauso groß auch der Raum,
wie groß ein Postleitzahlengebiet sein kann.
Das heißt, so eine Postleitzahl, die kann auch gerne mal irgendwie einen Durchmesser von 50, 60 Kilometer haben.
Wenn ich mir angucke, wie so gerade in meinem Heimatland hier mitten in Sachsen-Anhalt die Landkreise plötzlich aussehen, die sind ja zehnmal so groß wie die in Bayern oder sowas zum Beispiel.
Ich habe jetzt mit Dresden im Kopf im Vergleich, wo wir, ich glaube, elf Postleitzahlen haben.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie viele es waren, aber eine ganze Reihe von Postleitzahlen für die ganze Stadt haben.
Und das ist ja auch immer so herrlich groß.
Ich meine, gut, das System ist interessant.
Da gibt es viele witzige Feinheiten, wie die Tatsache, dass die hier in Dresden tatsächlich beginnen, in Deutschland weit zu zählen.
Deswegen haben wir auch die führende Null hier, was ja in vielen Webformularen oftmals nicht angenommen wird,
was immer so ein beschissenes Detail ist, wenn die Postleitzahlen als Integer speichern.
Oder so witzige Sachen wie die TU,
die zum Beispiel ihre eigene Postleitzahl hat.
Und wenn man früher am Fachschaftsrat
eine Postkarte aus dem Urlaub schicken wollte,
dann konnte man da auch einfach nur die Postleitzahl der TU draufschreiben.
Das ist die 01062.
Die sage ich immer, wenn mich jemand nach meiner Postleitzahl fragt.
Genau, genau.
Und dann noch IFSR dazu, IFSR 01062 Dresden.
Und dann kam das an.
Das fand ich großartig.
Einfach vier Buchstaben und eine Zahl.
Und das war's.
Das fand ich immer toll.
Was muss man wohl machen,
um eine eigene Postleitzahl zu bekommen?
Alt sein.
Also schon länger da sein.
Du kaufst dir ein Haus mitten in der Landschaft irgendwo in Brandenburg und sagst, du bist jetzt deine eigene Stadt.
Und dann gibt es ja noch Städte wie Büsingen, die haben sogar mehrere Postleitzahlen, weil die auch in mehreren Ländern sind.
Ah je. Okay, vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz zum Anfang.
Also es hat angefangen mit ein paar Freundinnen von hier aus München und die haben gesagt, wir müssen das jetzt machen.
Und die kannten zufälligerweise ein, zwei Leute, die sich mit Computern und dem Einrichten von Webservices.
auskannten.
Ja, und die kannten noch viel
mehr Leute. Also das ist
so ein bisschen in
dem Dunstkreis eines
anderen Projektes entstanden, nämlich
Breakout. Darüber kann man
glaube ich nochmal eine ganz andere Frage machen.
Ah ja, den Dunstkreis kenne ich auch so ein bisschen.
Genau, der
Florian S. Punkt ist da auch mit dabei.
Das ist doch bestimmt auch
gut zu. Hey Flo.
Grüße.
Ja genau, und in dem Dunstkreis gibt es viele Menschen, die sich gerne engagieren wollen, die Bock haben auf Non-Profit-Projekte und als das Ganze dann irgendwie so, ich glaube, gestartet ist das Ganze mit drei Personen und so nach einer Woche war man dann schon zu zehnt und ich glaube, nach zwei Wochen waren wir dann knapp 20 Leute im Team.
wirklich an der Entwicklung beteiligt.
Das war wie so häufig eigentlich das kleinste Team.
Also das waren so vier oder fünf Leute
und es ging dann wirklich viel um Marketing,
um Presse, um Social Media, um Support auch.
Was ja auch unterschätzt wird.
Wenn du so ein Projekt mit mehr als fünf Entwicklern machst,
dann wird es ja, je mehr Leute du draufwirfst,
dann auch irgendwann schon wieder langsamer.
Deswegen ist wahrscheinlich,
ist das so der Sweet Spot, den ihr da gehabt habt.
Und das heißt, ihr habt...
Und das sollte ja auch klein und
wenig komplex bleiben.
Also wir hatten kein Interesse
daran,
diese Probleme, die wir
gesehen haben, mit Raketenwissenschaft
zu lösen, sondern wir
wussten, das Ganze muss einfach
sein. Wir wollen möglichst wenige
Schritte in der User Experience haben,
aber es muss irgendwie stabil sein und
gut funktionieren.
Vor allem, weil wir unsere Zielgruppe von, keine Ahnung, von zehn Jahren von Kindern, die irgendwie für die Großeltern Inserate erstellt haben, weil es Oma und Opa selber nicht hinbekommen haben, bis zu irgendwie 90 plus, sollten irgendwie alle Menschen das verstehen.
Deswegen waren die technischen Herausforderungen ja nicht so groß und nicht so viele und wir hatten an anderen Stellen mehr zu tun.
Und das heißt, habt ihr euch dafür irgendwie einen legalen Rahmen gesucht?
Habt ihr irgendwie, macht das jeder, seid ihr einfach so eine lose Kopplung von Leuten, die das organisieren?
Und jeder hilft so ein bisschen und jeder gibt so ein bisschen, ein paar von den Sachen kosten ja auch Geld, jeder gibt ein bisschen was dazu.
Oder habt ihr einen Verein gegründet, wie man das ja in Deutschland macht, wenn drei Leute zusammenstehen, dass sie dann irgendwie einen Verein gründen?
Ja, also mit drei Leuten schaffst du es nicht, einen Verein zu gründen.
Du brauchst sieben, so viel ich weiß.
Und tatsächlich haben wir auch einen Verein gegründet,
aber das kam dann ein bisschen später.
Also wir haben wirklich am Anfang,
es war wirklich so ein bisschen Startup-Feeling,
irgendwie Wachstum, Wachstum, Wachstum.
Und alles ging ganz schnell.
Und ich glaube, der erste Lockdown,
der ging für mich auch so schnell vorbei,
weil wir irgendwie jeden Tag gefühlt von 9 bis 21 Uhr
hingen und gemeinsam gearbeitet haben, gebrainstormt haben, wie geht es jetzt weiter, was sind die
nächsten Features. Wir hatten so viele User, wir hatten so viele Anfragen, das war super
aufregend und irgendwann, als das Ganze dann ein bisschen abkühlte, ich glaube so Ende
Mai, haben wir dann alle so ein bisschen gespürt, die Zahlen gehen runter, Leute sind irgendwie
wieder ein bisschen unbeschwerter unterwegs. Das haben wir dann bei uns auf der Plattform
auch gespürt. Also so schnell, wie die
Userzahlen
nach oben schossen
im März und April, so schnell ging es
dann auch im Mai und Juni wieder runter.
Und dann habt ihr euch gedacht, na gut, dann brauchen wir
die Plattform, können wir ja bald wieder ausmachen.
Naja, nee, also wir haben
tatsächlich schon immer gesagt, wir
lassen das so lange laufen, wie
das Leute nutzen und brauchen.
Wir waren ja von Anfang an Open Source
unterwegs
und haben auch gesagt, wir wollen irgendwie schauen,
dass es vielleicht auch in anderen Ländern unser
einfach kopiert wird und auch diese
Plattform hochgezogen wird. Also
wir wussten schon, dass wir das so lange
wie es gebraucht wird, wie es genutzt
wird, betreiben wollen. Aber wir haben dann auch
irgendwann gesagt, wir brauchen jetzt einen vernünftigen
Rahmen und haben uns dann
entschieden, letztendlich einen eigenen Verein
zu gründen.
Und haben das dann auch in den letzten...
Ich glaube, die Gründungsversammlung war dann im September.
Ach ja, und jetzt gibt es
Quarantäneheldinnen e.V. oder
wie heißt der Verein?
Jetzt gibt es den Option 26 e.V. und Quarantäne-Heldinnen ist ein Projekt dieses Vereins.
Der Name ist der Option 26.
Gut, dass du fragst.
Dafür ist er da.
Das war so eine super witzige Geschichte.
Wie alles in einem Verein wurde natürlich auch die Frage des Namens basisdemokratisch bestimmt.
Das war der 26. Vorschlag für den Namen.
Genau und die Person, die das Doodle erstellt hat oder ich weiß nicht mehr, welches Tool wir damals genutzt haben, hat einmal zu viel auf neue Optionen hinzufügen geklickt und dann hatten wir dann Option 26 auch einmal standen zur Wahl und nachdem Option 26 nach der ersten Wahlrunde in die Stichwahl kam, war dann so die Leitung so gesagt, die Wahlleitung, okay, wir müssen jetzt wirklich mal drüber nachdenken,
ob wir uns vorstellen können, mit diesem Namen einen Verein zu gründen.
In der Stichwahl hat dann Option 26 haushoch die Abstimmung gewonnen.
Und so wurde dieser wunderbare Verein.
Das ist klassischer Namensgebungs-Fail.
Wenn du nicht aufpasst, hast du einen Podcast, der akronomisierbar heißt.
Aber unsere Idee war bei dem Verein von vornherein schon sozusagen,
Wir gründen das jetzt als Verein, der auch in Zukunft als Trägerorganisation für ähnliche Projekte dienen soll.
Ich hatte ja schon gesagt, dass viele Leute aus dem Quarantäneheld in dem Team schon am Projekt Breakout mitgearbeitet haben.
Damals wurde auch ein Verein gegründet.
Dieses Mal haben wir uns einfach gesagt, unser Freundeskreis kommt immer mal wieder an den Punkt, wo man ein Projekt ins Leben gerufen hat. Es ist ein Non-Profit-Projekt. Wie bauen wir das jetzt organisatorisch auf? Und jedes Mal wieder einen Verein zu gründen, ist dann doch irgendwie schon ein bisschen Overhead.
Auf jeden Fall.
Deswegen haben wir gesagt, gründen wir jetzt mal unseren eigenen Trägerverein, der dann in Zukunft neue Projekte auch unter seine...
Das ist auch schön, wenn man da einmal organisiert ist und die Infrastruktur am Laufen hat, dann kann man ja, wenn man die drei Entwickler, die man hat, mal schnell hinsetzt, auch kleine neue zusätzliche Sachen noch bauen, die vielleicht Ergänzungen zu der existierenden Quarantäne-Helden-App ist. Wahrscheinlich.
Du hattest vorhin gesagt, dass ihr auch von der Presse überall direkt mit aufgenommen wurdet. Das hat ja wahrscheinlich gut dazu geführt, dass die Popularität der Plattform gut zugenommen hat und ihr bekannter wart und Leute das genutzt haben. Ich meine, man braucht ja natürlich für so ein schwarzes Brett auch beide Seiten. Du willst ja Leute, die helfen, Leute, die Hilfesuche haben. Wenn du nur eins hast, dann bringt das ja nicht viel.
Ja, total. Also ich glaube, bei uns am besten funktioniert hat gefühlt Social Media, wobei unsere eigene Datenbasis dazu jetzt nicht so aussagekräftig ist. Wir haben halt jetzt nicht so viel getrackt.
Ich weiß noch, als wir das erste Mal einen ZDF-Beitrag hatten, saßen wir alle ganz angespannt vor Google Analytics und haben uns gefragt, okay, wenn jetzt das ausgestrahlt wird, fünf Minuten später werden die Webseitenaufrufe durch die Decke gehen oder als die Deutschlandfunk-Beiträge ausgestrahlt wurden.
Aber das war dann tatsächlich nicht ganz so krass.
Man hat schon was gesehen, aber nicht das, was man so irgendwie aus, keine Ahnung,
der Social Network aus dem Film erwartet hat.
Jetzt sind die Pipes offen, jetzt geht's los.
Jetzt explodiert alles, genau.
Und jetzt ruft gleich Google bei uns an und sagt, was soll das eigentlich?
Wer seid ihr hier?
Ihr fackelt ein Datencenter ab.
Das heißt, achso, genau, ihr lauft bei Firebase, das heißt, ihr lauft bei Google.
Und ich habe auch gerade gehört, ihr benutzt Google Analytics.
Das heißt, so richtig, das ist jetzt eine gewagte Frage, aber so ein bisschen Daten der Nutzer bekommt er dann doch?
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, wie der genaue Unterschied zwischen Google Analytics und den Firebase Analytics ist.
Bei Firebase kommt da ja so ein bisschen was mit.
Wir hatten auch mal die Diskussion oder wir haben mal diskutiert,
davon wegzugehen, um eben Abhängigkeiten zu den Google-Diensten zu reduzieren,
weil wir ja zum Beispiel auch als Google-Dienst die Google Maps API eingebunden haben.
Und damals war so der Outcome der Diskussion,
dass wir gerade auch im Team Technik irgendwie schon große Lust hätten,
das zu machen und das auch auf eigene Beine zu setzen.
Aber dass wir dann immer leider sagen mussten,
dass wir die Kapazitäten dazu nicht haben.
Ein Punkt war ja auch, weshalb unser Team so wachsen konnte
im März und April.
Es war ja nicht nur, oder der Lockdown damals bedeutete ja auch,
dass auf einmal ganz viele ArbeitnehmerInnen
so nach Hause geschickt wurden, in Kurzarbeit waren
und zu Hause saßen und sich gedacht haben,
okay, was fange ich jetzt an mit meiner Zeit?
Und so war das auch bei vielen Leuten von uns,
dass wir auf einmal alle im Homeoffice waren,
alle super viel Zeit hatten, super flexibel waren,
da Zeit reinstecken konnten
und vor allem schnell das Ganze hochziehen wollen.
Und da ist man so ein paar Kompromisse eingegangen,
auf die man vielleicht down the road nicht mehr ganz so stolz ist.
Aber die Zeit hat dann eben noch nicht aufgereicht.
Du hast ja auch gesagt, ihr wolltet das Ganze ohne Rocket Science erschlagen.
Und da finde ich das bei so einem Projekt auch durchaus angemessen,
das pragmatisch auf diese Art und Weise zu lösen,
zu sagen, wir nehmen jetzt hier bewiesene und bereits existierende
und bekannte Technologien und erfinden nicht das Rad neu.
Häufig scheitern ja solche Projekte, wenn ich sowas machen würde zum Beispiel,
grundsätzlich daran, dass man immer erstmal schaut,
ja, aber ich möchte da bestimmte Technologien verwenden
und deswegen kommt das gar nicht erst zum Einsatz zum Schluss.
Und deswegen war ich eigentlich erstaunt,
wie schnell diese Plattform überhaupt am Start war.
Also es war ja wirklich im April,
gab es schon den Nachrichtenbeitrag beim ZDF-Vorder.
Ja, ich weiß nicht mal ganz genau, wann der ausgestrahlt wurde,
aber wir waren in Woche 1 des ersten Lockdowns,
das war Anfang März, ich weiß nicht,
ich glaube, es war die zweite
Märzwoche,
war die Idee geboren und
zwei Tage später war die Plattform online.
Zweit. Das hat sich dann natürlich
am Design hat sich dann noch einiges
geändert und es sind einige Features
dazugekommen und so und das Ganze
drumherum ist dann gewachsen, aber
so der Proof of Concept,
die Plattform, die Möglichkeit zu inserieren
und Hilfe anzubieten,
Hilfe zu suchen. Das ist beeindruckend.
Das war in zwei, drei Tagen
über Nacht hatten die Jungs und Mädels
das da ausprogrammiert
und das war wirklich
faszinierend und ich glaube, das hätte
ohne die Nutzung dieser
Technologien, hätte
das dann auch nicht so schnell geklappt. Das ist so ein bisschen
immer die Frage. So, ich schaue jetzt hier mal ganz kurz drauf
und
scroll hier mal durch. Es gibt ja wie gesagt den Button, ich möchte
helfen oder ich brauche Hilfe.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle auch sagen, euer Artwork
und die Symbole sind super schön.
Also auch dieses Quarantäne-Heldin-Logo
ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Ja, ist dir schon aufgefallen, dass das Logo
Genderfluid ist?
Darauf möchte ich jetzt...
Okay, inwiefern?
Wir haben nämlich lange
am Anfang ganz, also das hat sich auch entwickelt
am Anfang war das ein Quarantäne-Held
ein Superhero, der dann
im Laufe der Zeit noch
Brüste bekommt. Also ein bisschen
erkennt man es, aber die Auflösung von meinem Bildschirm ist leider
nicht gut genug.
Wir wollten dann aber explizit
auch nicht lange Haare, das sollte alles fluid
sein. In dem Zusammenhang
ist dann auch das
Gendern der Plattform irgendwie dazu gekommen.
Also wir haben dann auch,
je größer das Team wurde, umso mehr
Perspektiven sind dann auch irgendwie ins
Projekt eingebracht worden, was dann wieder
total viel Spaß gemacht hat.
Eine Sache, auf die wir zum Beispiel
auch sehr stolz waren,
war, dass dann unsere, die Plattform
selbst, das haben wir leider noch
nicht geschafft, aber wir haben auch so einen kleinen Aushang.
Falls man
möchte, kann man sich auch so einen kleinen
Aushang da herunterladen,
um ihn im Treppenhaus, im Kiez einfach
so aufzuhängen. Ich suche Hilfe.
Achso, das ist Quarantäneheldin zum Ausdrucken quasi.
Das ist Quarantäneheldin
zum Ausdrucken. Das haben wir dann auch
mit der Hilfe von vielen Freundinnen
in 18 Sprachen übersetzen können.
Ehrlich.
Die Website an sich gibt es
leider noch nicht auf 18 Sprachen.
Aber das wäre auch eine... Es wäre schön
gewesen, das in anderen Ländern auch zu sehen.
Aber das hat leider...
Naja, du machst ja die Sprache auch nicht nur für die anderen Länder, weil da müsstest du ja tatsächlich auch dein System mit Karten und Postleitzahlen noch für andere Länder zur Verfügung stellen und erweitern.
Aber was zum Beispiel ein Kritikpunkt ist, den ich häufig auch von Leuten gehört habe, ist diese ganze Bekanntmachung bei uns, das ist ja in Dresden, was so demnächst für Regeln und Ausgangssperren und besondere Einschränkungen gelten, ist von der Stadt lange Zeit häufig nur auf Deutsch veröffentlicht worden.
Und das hätte man mindestens noch auf Englisch,
wenn nicht sogar auch noch auf Türkisch oder Arabisch veröffentlichen können.
Das ist natürlich auch ein Auffang.
Der Start sollte man zutrauen können, das machen zu können.
Das stimmt schon.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Was ich zumindest gerade sagen wollte,
wenn ich jetzt hier durchscrolle,
man sieht jetzt hier so ein bisschen Metriken.
Es gibt momentan 1.238 Anfragen,
38.000 noch noch Heldinnen und 6.300 Nachrichten.
ähm, also ich find's schön, dass man hier sehen kann, wie viele
Leute es gibt, die
die sich als Hilfe anbieten
oder als Held anbieten und es gibt
eine Zahl, wie viele Leute
Hilfe suchen, aber habt ihr
eventuell auch eine Metrik dafür
wie viele Matches ihr habt
also wie häufig passiert es, dass wirklich
ein Held
einer anderen Person hilft
äh, ist das, habt ihr dafür
irgendwie eine Zahl, könnt ihr das, bekommt ihr das überhaupt
mit oder ist das, ich kann dir mir vorstellen, ist das
einfach bloß ganz viele Leute gibt, die sich
die Nachhilfe suchen und viele, die
sich melden, aber man weiß vielleicht zum Schluss
gar nicht, ob die Leute sich auch untereinander finden.
Wisst ihr das?
Ja, also wir haben
so langsam wird unsere Datenbasis dazu
besser, weil wir vor einiger
Zeit das Feature released
haben, dass man selbst
das eigene Inserat als gelöst
markieren kann. Das hatten
wir vorher nicht.
Wir hatten auch
dadurch, dass wir
wir selbst mit unserer Plattform auch so wenig wie möglich
Daten selbst halten wollten, haben wir auch gesagt,
entweder über den Weg der E-Mail-Adresse oder über den Weg der
Hotline stellen wir die Verbindung der beteiligten
Personen her und wie dann geholfen wird, wie genau das dann abläuft,
das besprechen oder sprechen die Personen untereinander
ab. Das heißt, wenn der Kontakt hergestellt ist,
Dann kriegen wir danach oder beginnen wir jetzt erst so langsam, so ein bisschen mehr Informationen darüber zu bekommen, was passiert danach.
Was wir wissen, woran ich mich noch erinnern kann, unser Data Science Team hat beim letzten großen Meeting mal ein paar Statistiken veröffentlicht.
Und der Median für die Anzahl der Nachrichten auf ein Inserat war 1,04.
Das bedeutet, also das war für uns eine gute Metrik, weil das heißt, Anfragen werden beantwortet.
Leute, die Hilfe suchen, finden diese Hilfe auch.
Es gibt natürlich immer mal wieder ein Inserat, das dann leider so ländlich ist, dass entweder nicht mal Benachrichtigungen rausgehen oder wenn die Benachrichtigungen rausgehen,
dann sich tatsächlich leider einfach niemand meldet
oder Anfragen sind zu speziell.
Mit ländlich meinst du wirklich, dass die Leute,
die da Hilfe suchen, so weit weg von allen anderen potenziellen Teilnehmern sind,
dass denen auch nicht geholfen werden kann?
Also wir müssen sagen, dass unsere Plattform funktioniert
am besten in den großen Metropolen Deutschlands.
In München, in Berlin, in Köln, in Hamburg.
Das ist auch häufig so ein Problem von diesen Plattformen.
Das scheitert halt daran,
dass die Leute es nicht benutzen oder dass es eine zu wenige Teilnehmerzahl gibt?
Also unsere und die optimistische Interpretation dieser Verteilung war für uns,
dass im ländlichen Raum die Hilfe in der Nachbarschaft ohne solche Plattformen besser funktioniert.
Vielleicht Verknüpfungen in der Familie enger sind und dass sozusagen die Anonymität der Stadt dazu führt, dass solche Plattformen benötigt werden, um die Hilfe im Kiez zu organisieren.
Wir haben von Anfang an gesagt, in einer idealen Gesellschaft müsste es Quarantäne-Heldinnen nicht geben.
So in einer funktionierenden Gesellschaft würde man im Familien- oder Freundinnenkreis das selbst organisieren.
Aber leider ist das nicht so.
Ja, es gibt ja auch in der Stadt oder auch auf dem Dorf gibt es dann immer noch die Leute,
die ein bisschen isolierter sind und keinen großen Freundeskreis haben.
Oder die Oma, die halt keine Familie vor Ort hat.
Oder wo jemand da ist.
Da hast du Kontakt zu den Nachbarn.
In der idealen Gesellschaft wird das echt funktionieren irgendwie.
Aber gut, da kann man einfach nicht sein.
In der idealen Gesellschaft braucht man das halt nicht.
Du hast halt immer die Möglichkeit, Nachbarn zu haben,
mit denen du kennst.
Es sei denn, du wohnst dann wirklich alleine im Wald irgendwo.
Aber dann musst du natürlich erst mal jemanden finden,
der überhaupt vorbeikommen kann, zu helfen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Aber wenn du alleine im Wald wohnst,
dann kommst du wahrscheinlich auch so klar.
Es sei denn, du bist gerade wirklich selber tatsächlich krank.
Ich glaube, es ist auch schwierig, wenn man in der Stadt von Familie und Freundinnen so ein bisschen entfernt wohnt.
Also es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt gleich die nächste Wohnung im Haus, sondern vielleicht doch irgendwie ein anderer Stadtteil.
Für viele Menschen kommt ja diese Situation der Quarantäne
dann am Ende doch auch ein bisschen überrascht.
Das ist ja nichts, worauf man sich vorbereitet.
Man steht morgens auf vielleicht und merkt auf einmal,
verdammt, ich schmecke nichts mehr.
Man entwickelt Symptome oder man bekommt den Anruf vom Gesundheitsamt,
bitte begeben Sie sich in Quarantäne,
weil Sie sind als Kontaktperson einer positiv getesteten Person
identifiziert worden.
Und dann steht man da und dann ist die Hürde ja auch groß zu sagen,
okay, ich gehe jetzt nochmal raus im Haus und klingel mal bei meiner Nachbarin,
könnten sie vielleicht für mich einkaufen gehen.
Ich glaube, das sind so viele soziale Aspekte und Phänomene, die dazu führen,
dass unsere Plattform in Städten, in Ballungszentren eine größere Nutzung erfährt.
So, ich klicke mich jetzt hier gerade zum Spaß mal so ein bisschen durch.
Ich habe jetzt hier meine Postleitzahl eingegeben
und bin jetzt auf dem Feld, lass dich benachrichtigen,
wenn jemand in deiner Umgebung Hilfe braucht.
Und das funktioniert tatsächlich so,
dass ich tatsächlich einfach meine Postleitzahl
und meine E-Mail-Adresse angebe
und dann bekomme ich von euch E-Mails mit den Anfragen.
Genau, wir filtern da bei uns gerade noch so ein bisschen,
dass wir jetzt in Berlin nicht irgendwie auf jedes Inserat
10.000 E-Mails rausschicken.
Weil wir auch mit den wenigen E-Mails, die wir verschicken,
haben wir auch relativ schnell das Problem gehabt,
auf Spam-Listen zu landen.
Du willst ja Leute auch eigentlich nicht überfordern.
Aber genau, so funktioniert das.
Dass für jedes Inserat in einer Metropole wie Berlin
2000 Leute benachrichtigt werden,
auch wenn das potenziell praktisch wäre,
um auch aufmerksam zu machen.
Dann, wenn die Leute hier 2000 E-Mails bekommen,
weil ein paar Inserate auftauchen,
dann sagen die auch ganz schnell,
nee, warte mal, ich glaube, ich will da doch nicht mehr drauf schauen.
Ihr habt da ein bisschen Logik draufgeworfen,
dass er irgendwie sagt, wir machen so irgendwie Round-Drobin
oder sowas, dass wir
versuchen, die Leute möglichst gleichmäßig
zu benachrichtigen oder
macht er das einfach ganz naiv?
Ganz naiv mit ein bisschen random.
Also wir picken die Leute nach
mit ein bisschen Randomness. Wir picken die Leute
erstmal aus der Liste, wer ist im Umkreis
und dann picken wir uns dort
100 aus. Weil ich bin jetzt hier
in einem kleinen Ort
mitten in Sachsen-Anhalt und wenn ich meine Postleitzahl
angebe, dann
bin ich direkt einmal an eine Grenze eurer
UI gestoßen.
Dann ist nämlich so eine Liste mit 15 Orten
aufgepoppt, die alle die gleiche Postleitzahl
haben.
Nämlich die ganzen Dörfer, die um meinen Ort drum rum
liegen. Und dann ist mir gerade aufgefallen, dass ich hier noch
scrollen muss. Ich dachte mir, hä, meine Stadt
kommt hier gar nicht vor. Ach, warte. Ach so, ich kann
scrollen. Da kommt noch mehr.
Ich kann dir ja mal zum Debuggen die Postleitzahl
weitergeben. Vielleicht könnte das...
Ja, immer her damit.
So, genau. Und dann kriegt man
Also von euch eine E-Mail. Das ist ja ziemlich cool.
Und hast du irgendwie ein bisschen...
Oder klärt?
Wie funktioniert das mit der Hotline?
Kann ich dann anrufen und Dinge eintragen lassen in meinem Namen?
Totalsgesuch?
Ja, genau.
An der Hotline haben wir lange gearbeitet.
Wir haben lange Zeit gedacht, brauchen wir das überhaupt?
Müssen wir das auf die Beine stellen?
Es gab andere Plattformen, die von Beginn an eine Hotline hatten, wo man auch anrufen konnte und dann passierte irgendwas.
Dann wussten wir aber immer nicht so richtig, was passiert.
Man hat dann über den Sommer auch gemerkt, dass viele ähnliche Plattformen offline gegangen sind und nicht weitergemacht haben.
Und dann haben wir irgendwann gesagt, okay, um einen Zugang zu schaffen für Menschen, die nicht so internetaffin sind, Menschen, die vielleicht auch einfach eine persönlichere Betreuung suchen oder einfach mal eine Frage auch loswerden wollen, bauen wir jetzt die Hotline.
und bei der Hotline ist es tatsächlich so,
dass wir selbst zwischen den Vereinsmitgliedern
so ein kleines Hotline-Sheet uns aufgebaut haben,
was die Schichten scheduled, wo man sich eintragen kann.
Und wenn man bei der Hotline anruft, dann wird weitergeleitet.
Und dann klingeln bei uns die Handys.
Und wer zuerst rangeht, darf das Telefonat annehmen.
Und dann werden intern Listen gepflegt.
Und dann stellen wir sozusagen,
also wir inserieren dann im Namen der Personen
auf der Online-Plattform mit dem Zusatz,
dass es sich hier um ein Hotline-Inserat handelt
und dass im nächsten Schritt der Kontaktaufnahme
wir die Telefonnummern sozusagen tauschen und weitergeben,
dass die Menschen sich über Telefonen erreichen können.
Ich finde das ganz toll.
Ich wollte gerade fragen, so was wie eine Webseite bauen,
wo man der eine Inserate aufgibt und der andere sie sieht,
das kann ich mir vorstellen, wie das geht.
Das habe ich auch schon dreimal gemacht.
Aber wie betreibt man eine Hotline?
total großartig.
Da habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch irgendwo
einen Asterisk oder
einen Telefonservice laufen, der dann
habt ihr da ein bisschen
auf den Schelf genommen oder ist das auch selbst gebaut?
Ja, Software as a Service.
Twilio benutzen
wir dann. Das war ein Anbieter, den ich
persönlich vorher nicht kannte,
die aber uns
auch entgegengekommen sind mit
Support für Non-Project.
Das ist ja das Schöne, dass es
immer mal wieder
oder dass eigentlich fast alle großen Plattformanbieter,
Software-as-a-Service-Unternehmen,
Non-Profit-Support irgendwie anbieten.
Und bei Twilio waren es dann auch so ein paar Plattform-Credits.
Und diese Plattform-Credits,
die reizen wir dann auch immer schön jeden Monat aus.
Aber deren Angebot hat uns geholfen,
diese Hotline schnell auf die Beine zu stellen,
was im Prinzip eine Weiterleitung ist.
Die Leute rufen bei der 0800er Nummer an.
Das dann klingelt bei Twilio, der Service.
Und der schaut dann in unser Google-Sheet und leitet das Ganze weiter.
Also stimmt, das war noch so eine Geschichte am Anfang vom ersten Lockdown,
dass die viele Plattformanbieter, auch so Videokonferenzanbieter
und unterschiedliche Kommunikationsanbieter
plötzlich für bestimmte, hauptsächlich Krankenhäuser oder Schulen,
bestimmte kostenlose Angebote gemacht haben.
Habt ihr davon profitiert selber?
Habt ihr irgendwie Firebase umsonst bekommen oder so?
Firebase umsonst bekommen haben wir nicht. Google hat damals aber auch einen Covid-Relief-Fund. Also es gab auf jeden Fall damals auch bei Google so ein Programm, das dann schnell aufgesetzt wurde, um Unternehmen, die irgendwas im Zusammenhang mit Covid machen, zu unterstützen.
und auch dort haben wir Plattform-Credits bekommen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, wie viel das war,
aber es handelte sich dort damals auch um,
sag ich mal, so einmalige Projekte.
Wir haben dann auch, als die Plattform-Credits
dann aufgebraucht waren,
war es dann auch kein Problem,
nochmal so einen Nachschub zu bekommen
und im Prinzip, was uns dort entgegengebracht wurde,
war, hey, wir finden das cool, was ihr macht,
wir möchten euch gerne unterstützen.
Aber ja, das war auch nichts Langfristiges, weshalb für uns jetzt so langsam das Thema aufkommt, zu schauen, wie können wir diese Plattform auch nachhaltig finanzieren.
Wir haben jetzt im ersten Jahr aus eigenen Taschen viel reingesteckt und irgendwie zusammengeschmissen.
Dort, wo Unterstützung der Plattform nicht ausgereicht hat, da hilft uns natürlich jetzt auch der Verein und die Gemeinnützigkeit,
weil wir eben Spenden annehmen können, Spendenquittungen ausstellen können.
Das erleichtert die Finanzierung eines solchen Projekts auch enorm.
Das ist eine Frage, die ich mir gerade aufgeschrieben hatte.
Nicht nur, dass ihr Hilfe anbietet,
sondern euch kann natürlich auch wahrscheinlich geholfen werden.
Und ihr seid ein Verein, den man also steuerfrei spenden kann dementsprechend.
Ja, genau. Uns kann man steuerfrei spenden.
Unsere Finanzplanung, unser Budget, unsere Kosten, das ist alles nicht so komplex und nicht so hoch.
Glücklicherweise kommen wir noch mit relativ wenig Geld auch aus.
Firebase ist tatsächlich unglaublich günstig.
Also ich glaube für den kompletten Betrieb der Plattform seit März ist unser gesamtes Firebase-Budget im ganz niedrigen zweistelligen Bereich.
Wirklich Wahnsinn.
Man kann uns schon über PayPal spenden. Wir sind gerade noch dabei, das Spendenkonto dann auch einzurichten und arbeiten gerade auch jetzt schon an einem Transparenzbericht, wo wir das alles so ein bisschen aufschlüsseln wollen.
Was sind unsere Kosten? Wofür wird das Geld verwendet? Was ist unser Outlook? Was brauchen wir, um, sage ich mal, für ein Jahr das Ganze zu betreiben? Das kommt jetzt alles in den nächsten, da arbeiten wir sozusagen gerade dran.
Dann verweise ich jetzt an die Links bei uns in den Shownotes, wo wir das noch nachdenken.
Ansonsten freuen wir uns auch immer über Open-Source-Contributions.
Quarantäne-Heldinnen als Projekt ist bei GitHub auch zu finden.
Das ist jetzt vielleicht schon ein Vorgriff auf den.
Das könnte ja fast ein Pick der Woche sein.
Die Organisation.
Ein bisschen Fragen zur Materie hätte ich eigentlich schon noch.
Dann machen wir das ganz kurz.
der Organisation Option 26
findet man das
Quarantäne erhältenden Projekt
und da hatten wir
auch am Anfang, im ersten Lockdown
hatten wir da ein paar Contributions,
es hat richtig Spaß gemacht, dann auch mit
externen Contributions da mal zusammenzuarbeiten,
das intern dann zu reviewen,
die Prozesse irgendwie abzubilden,
wie kriegen wir das alles hin,
wie können wir auch das Projekt aufziehen,
damit externe Contributions
erleichtert werden.
Das war also für mich vor allem...
Erste Frage ist mal, wie baue ich den Scheiß?
Ich kriege es.
Ja, genau.
Ja, es gab einige Pull-Requests auf die Readme.
Deswegen, wer Lust hat, schaut euch das gerne an, schaut vorbei.
Es gibt einige Issues, auch immer noch.
Da gibt es noch einiges zu tun.
Nice. Und ihr seid auch, wie ich das gerade mitbekommen habe,
ein Verein von komplett Freiwilligen, die das
alle nebenbei
unentgeltlich machen
momentan noch.
Das heißt,
da ist es dann natürlich auch
gut, wenn man ein bisschen gerade
die zeitaufwendigen Sachen eventuell unterstützt.
Nicht nur, wenn man einen Bug findet, sagt,
hier ist er, sondern eventuell gleich noch die
anderthalb Stunden investiert, ihn selber zu fixen.
Vielleicht probiere ich das nachher sogar.
Ich will nicht zu viel gesagt haben.
So,
mir ist vorhin noch eine Frage
ähm
du hast gesagt, es gab noch andere
Plattformen, die im gleichen
Zeitraum entstanden sind
die ein ähnliches Problem
lösen wollten oder das gleiche Problem mitlösen
wollten, die sich dann allerdings mit der Zeit
aufgelöst haben, was mir als
aller allererstes als Frage eingefallen war
als wir angefangen haben
ist, normalerweise hätte sich ja
sowas über Facebook gelöst, in
USA kann ich mir vorstellen, dass
viele solch hier Sachen auch über sowas wie
Craigslist
abgewickelt werden könnten.
Und in Deutschland gibt es eBay-Kleinanzeigen.
Das war
allerdings alles für euch.
Ihr wolltet was haben, was ein Aushängeschild
ist und was wo wirklich explizit
dieser Quarantänehelfer-Gedanke
mit dran steht.
Was hat den Ausschlag gegeben zu sagen,
nee, wir wollen nicht,
dass die Leute eBay-Kleinanzeigen
benutzen oder Facebook benutzen?
Also,
Und ich kann bis zu einem gewissen Punkt mutmaßen gerade nur, was genau in den Köpfen vorging, als diese Idee entstanden ist.
Ich glaube, ein Punkt war auf jeden Fall auch, wir können das und wir haben Lust, das zu machen und wir haben Lust, das einfach mal zu bauen. Also so ein bisschen Neugier und das technische Interesse, sowas aufzusetzen, die war am Anfang auch auf jeden Fall, hat das eine große Rolle gespielt.
Und als das Ganze dann aufgebaut war und lief, war ein ganz großer Punkt, der aufkam, wie unterstützen wir Menschen sowohl bei der Suche nach Hilfe als auch beim Hilfe anbieten.
Sicherheitshinweise, wie können wir die Menschen belehren. Einerseits wollen wir nicht den Anschein erwecken, dass wir ein Dienstleister sind und dass jetzt unsere Angestellten Botengänge erfüllen.
Andererseits wollen wir natürlich aber dennoch, also sind wir uns der Verantwortung bewusst als Plattform, auf der wir Menschen irgendwie verbinden, dass wir so gut es uns nur möglich ist, Menschen darüber informieren müssen, worauf ist zu achten.
worauf sollt ihr aufpassen, um euch selber zu schützen?
Wie kann so eine Übergabe, so ein Einkaufen,
wie kann sowas ablaufen?
Wo findet man zusätzliche Informationen
zu allen möglichen Corona-Themen, die da irgendwie im Mail sind?
Und das funktioniert natürlich besser,
wenn man eine dedizierte Plattform ist,
die domain-spezifisch sich explizit damit beschäftigt
und nicht nur das generische schwarze Brett,
wo die Leute eine Seite später noch ihre alte Kuckucksufe kaufen oder sowas.
Ja, das macht durchaus Sinn.
Was ich am Anfang auch spannend fand,
als ich das erste Mal von euch gehört habe,
ist Quarantäne-Heldinnen oder Quarantäne-Helden.
Da gibt es auch ähnliche Services, auch deutschlandweit,
mit dem Namen Held im Namen, die den Leuten Sachen nach Hause bringen.
Ich war einen Tick überrascht,
dass diese Firmen nicht an Bord gesprungen sind und gesagt haben,
Ihr könnt, weil es ist ja genau der gleiche Dienst, die organisieren, dass dir jemand was vom Dönerladen nebenan vorbeibringt oder vom Pizzaladen oder von dem Restaurant um die Ecke.
Mich hat es noch ein bisschen gewundert, dass so ein Essensbringdienst nicht einfach auch mit an Bord gesprungen ist und gesagt hat, wir machen jetzt Einkaufen und Ausliefern.
Es gibt ja auch von den Supermarktketten,
als ich mich mal für zwei Wochen in Quarantäne begeben habe,
habe ich mir auch mein Essen, ehrlich gesagt,
von dem Supermarkt um die Ecke direkt online bestellt
und liefern lassen.
Auch, um es mal ausprobiert zu haben.
Aber deswegen frage ich jetzt,
ein gewisses Angebot, sich Sachen nach Hause bringen zu lassen,
oder so, das gibt es ja.
Und das ist ja auch nicht das Hauptding,
was Quarantänehelden machen.
Deswegen ist jetzt meine Frage, was siehst du so,
was sind die Sachen, die die Leute hauptsächlich
über Quarantäne-Helden abwickeln?
Du hast schon sowas wie mit dem Hund Kassi gehen gebracht,
aber was machen die Leute eigentlich mit der Plattform?
Die Frage nach, kann jemand oder möchte jemand
unseren Hund ausführen, die es in den letzten Wochen ganz beliebt.
Also es gibt dann auch immer so ein paar lustige Trends.
Was sind denn so die Trends? Ist das jahreszeitabhängig?
Also gerade in Leipzig war in den letzten zwei Wochen Hundeausführen ganz beliebt als Hilfsgesuch.
Gerade in der Weihnachtszeit oder in der Adventszeit gab es auch immer wieder Anfragen, bei denen ganz süß Enkel, Enkelkinder oder Kinder von älteren Menschen gesagt haben,
Meine Mutter, meine Oma oder mein Opa, die sind irgendwie in der Wohnung und ganz einsam und wir haben die schon lange nicht gesehen. Und die Oma hat Geburtstag nächste Woche und die würde sich freuen über eine Geburtstagskarte. Und dann wurde irgendwie über die Plattform organisiert oder diese Message da publiziert.
und dann irgendwie eine Woche später haben wir ein Screenshot
oder haben wir ein Foto bekommen von der Oma,
die 200 Geburtstagskarten auf ihrem Wohnzimmertisch liegen hat und so.
Habt ihr irgendwie einen Blog oder sowas mit den Erfolgsgeschichten,
wo ihr sowas dann...
Das fehlt wirklich noch, ja.
So, die herzerwärmenden Sachen haben wir bisher immer über Instagram gepostet.
Das war tatsächlich der Social Media-Link kommt in die Shownotes.
das war der Social-Media-Kanal, der für uns am besten funktioniert hat.
Twitter und Facebook hat irgendwie, hat mich so gezündet.
Aber schön, ja, also der Oma eine Freude tut.
Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass manche sagen,
oder ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass ich würde vielleicht so was fragen,
wie geht doch mal bitte einer mit dem Tablet zu meiner Oma,
dass ich mit der mal Video telefonieren kann.
Das geht ja auch selten.
Ja, also wir hatten ab und zu mal die Frage nach Hilfe beim Möbel aufbauen.
Oder ich glaube auch mal einen Fernseher einrichten.
Die Oma hat einen neuen Fernseher bekommen und die kann das nicht.
Das hatten wir auch.
Das ist ja super clever auch.
Es ist für uns immer ein bisschen schwierig, solche Inserate, User Generated Content.
Also wir haben uns auch, wir haben auch relativ früh gewusst, wir brauchen ja irgendwie, müssen wir ja auch moderieren.
sind da aber auch ganz niederschwellig an die Sache rangegangen
und haben da einen Mechanismus implementiert,
der uns sozusagen die Möglichkeit gibt,
als Admins Sachen zu veröffentlichen
oder eben nicht zu veröffentlichen.
Und gerade wenn es darum geht,
ältere Menschen in ihren eigenen vier Wänden zu unterstützen,
sind das dann häufig Sachen,
bei denen wir ja dann schon manchmal ein bisschen diskutieren intern,
weil es da in den sehr persönlichen Bereich reingeht
und weil auch, sage ich mal, was Corona-Infektionen angeht,
in den Räumen ist es dann auch alles nicht mehr so leicht.
Also wir versuchen da schon,
irgendwie die Menschen so zu erreichen und aufzuklären,
dass sie sich da wirklich gut überlegen,
welche Hilfe sie auch erfragen und dann annehmen
und wie das Ganze für sie am sichersten ausgestaltet werden kann.
Habt ihr dafür irgendwie eine Guideline
oder eine Best-Practice-Auflistung oder sowas?
Wir haben die wichtigsten Sicherheitshinweise für uns,
die haben wir gleich ganz kurz und knapp auf der Startseite.
Wichtige Hinweise, umsichtig.
Gleich gelistet.
Wir haben dann auch noch eine Unterseite mit ein paar FAQs.
Ich lese mal kurz diese wichtigen Hinweise vor,
weil ich das ganz spannend finde.
Also Punkt 1, umsichtig.
Helft nicht, wenn ihr einer Risikogruppe angehört.
Helft nicht, wenn ihr Sorge habt,
selbst eine Ansteckungsgefahr darzustellen.
Nicht sehr gut.
Lokal.
Helft eurer Nachbarschaft zum Beispiel euren Haus mit Bewohnern,
mit Bewohnerinnen.
Konsistent.
Helft wenigen, aber das konsistent.
Sucht euch zum Beispiel eine Familie und helft nur dieser.
Das ist auch ein ganz guter Punkt,
dass die Leute nicht selber zum Superspreader werden.
Oder sich zu sehr verstreuen oder ausbrennen,
weil sie irgendwie auf jede Anfrage antworten.
Das reicht ja, wenn man, wahrscheinlich kann ich mir vorstellen,
reicht es ja, wenn man einmal jemanden vermittelt,
weil der Hund möchte ja jeden Tag Gassig geführt werden wahrscheinlich.
Oder du möchtest ja regelmäßig für die Person einkaufen.
Deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich,
kommt aus einem so einem Match wahrscheinlich wesentlich mehr raus,
als ihr der Plattform ansehen könnt.
Und danach, sobald einmal ein Match gemacht ist,
Brauchen die Leute auch ihre Plattform dann wahrscheinlich nicht mehr,
weil dann einmal sich Telefonnummern ausgetauscht werden
und dann ruft man im Zweifelsfall wahrscheinlich einfach die Person nochmal an,
wenn die das nächste Mal einkaufen gehen soll oder so.
Genau, das sehen wir auch in unseren Daten.
Zumindest könnte man das optimistisch so interpretieren,
dass die Accounts im Schnitt auch nur eine Anfrage erstellen.
Es gibt auch Accounts, die dann mehrere Anfragen erstellen.
Wenn dann doch mal, also zum Beispiel hatten wir es schon,
dass eine Person, die dann eben internetaffin war,
von der Plattform gehört hat, dann für mehrere ältere,
verwandte und bekannte Inserate erstellt hat.
Sowas gibt es dann in seltenen Fällen auch,
aber meistens wird ein Inserat erstellt.
Und wir hoffen dann eben dadurch, dass wir auch sehen,
dass so gut wie alle Inserate Nachrichten bekommen,
beantwortet werden, dass dann diese Anfragen auch gelöst werden.
Aber wir hoffen natürlich, dass wir in Zukunft
das noch ein bisschen expliziter sehen,
durch eben die Möglichkeit zu sagen,
selbst als meine Anfrage als gelöst zu markieren.
Also wir hatten am Anfang so ein paar Überlegungen,
wie können wir die Nutzung der Plattform ein bisschen unterstützen.
Und wie in jedem guten Startup kommt ja dann natürlich schnell Gamification ins Spiel.
Und wir haben irgendwie über Superhero-Badges und sonst was nachgedacht oder gebrainstormt
und sind dann aber auch relativ schnell.
Irgendwie ist dann bei allen der Groschen gefallen,
Moment mal, eigentlich wäre das eine ganz, ganz doofe Idee.
Das ist genau das.
Weil wir eben auf gar keinen Fall wollen,
dass die Leute dann selbst zu Superspreadern werden.
Das ist das Gleiche, was ich überlegt hatte.
Man könnte bei der Corona-Warn-App irgendwie so Gamification mit reinmachen.
Du hast jetzt schon drei Tage ohne Risikokontakte gehabt oder sowas.
Aber das führt ja dann eventuell auch in die falsche Richtung.
Da werden dann ja die falschen Verhaltensweisen
inzentiviert vielleicht.
Das ist ja eine Maßnahme,
dass Leute halt wirklich geben,
wie viele Leute sich infiziert haben.
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Will man nicht.
Habt ihr schon mal die Notwendigkeit gehabt,
tatsächlich was zu moderieren, wo ihr gesehen habt,
hier geht jetzt gerade was schief
oder das ist alles nicht in Ordnung?
Ich könnte mir zum Beispiel vorstellen,
wenn man jetzt mal, du interpretierst immer Sachen
optimistisch, wie du jetzt ein paar Mal gesagt hast,
aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass diese Plattform für sowas wie
den Enkeltrick benutzt wird.
Ja. Ist euch sowas
schon mal aufgefallen oder wenn
ja, was habt ihr da gemacht oder konntet ihr da überhaupt
was machen?
Also der Enkeltrick ist jetzt eine Sache,
die ich glaube
nicht direkt als Inserat
auf der Plattform
landen würde, sondern das wäre dann
eher andersrum. Jemand sucht Hilfe
für eine ältere Person und dann
wird der Enkel
Trigg angewandt.
Dort ist es natürlich so,
dass wir
nicht wirklich einen Einblick haben,
was nach der Kontaktherstellung passiert.
Was
wir sagen können, ist eben,
dass wir für uns
festgelegt haben, wir wollen an jeder
Stelle, an der wir mit beteiligten Personen
in Kontakt treten, sei es
die Website selbst oder die
E-Mail-Benachrichtigungen, weisen wir eben
immer darauf hin,
macht nur Dinge, bei denen ihr
sicher fühlt. Eure eigene
Sicherheit ist das Wichtigste
und im Zweifel
lieber wieder Abstand
nehmen von der
Hilfsaktion. Und wir haben
bisher diesbezüglich noch
keinerlei negatives
Feedback sozusagen erhalten.
Es gab mal eine negative
Meldung, da ist jemand
nach einer Hilfsaktion auf uns zugekommen
und hat gesagt, dass er nicht so
zufrieden war, oder dass die Person
nicht so zerfrieden war, wie ich glaube,
es war damals die Übergabe von Einkäufen,
wie das ablief. Das war
wohl dann nicht
ganz so 100% sicher.
Aber
ansonsten ist das Feedback,
das wir direkt bekommen haben, bisher
immer positiv gewesen.
Manchmal müssen wir ein paar Sachen, ein paar
Inserate moderieren, die dann auf
Ebay-Kleinanzeigen wirklich besser aufgehoben werden.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn
dann jemand fragt,
mein Handy ist kaputt
und ich bin
gerade in Kurzarbeit
und kann mir kein neues Handy leisten.
Kann mir jemand ein Handy schicken.
Ja gut, okay.
Da gibt es wirklich bessere Plattformen für.
Das ist dann
so ein Beispiel, wo dann
der Anfragen-Bot eine Nachricht
rausschickt und sagt, Leute, ist das wirklich
was, was wir haben wollen? Und dann wird kurz
gewotet und dann
kommt das dann unter Umständen nicht
auf die Plattform und
die Person, die inseriert hat, bekommt
dann eine E-Mail
von uns mit der Erläuterung,
warum wir der Meinung sind, dass das
nicht dem Zweck herkommt. Das finde ich jetzt aber spannend.
Das heißt, ihr habt irgendwie ein technisches Hilfsmittel,
was das erkennt?
Ganz. Also wir
machen da keine große Sprachanalyse,
sondern es gibt
wie in jedem,
jetzt kommt wieder so diese Floske, wie in jedem
Startup ist natürlich
95 Prozent,
nein, nein,
davon haben wir uns bewusst
distanziert von Machine
Learning oder Statistik.
Aber 95 Prozent unserer
internen Prozesse sind natürlich
mit Slack abgebildet.
Deswegen.
Und da gibt es eine Keyboard-Suche.
Woher weiß der Bot,
wann da eine Nachricht rausgeht?
Woran macht er das fest?
Der Bot, der erkennt erstmal, wenn ein neues Inserat erstellt werden soll.
Und diese Inserate landen dann alle in unseren Moderations-Tanels.
Eigentlich sind alle Inserate moderiert hier.
Okay, verstehe.
Ja.
Also wir haben uns, ähnlich wie bei der Hotline,
haben wir uns auch bei der Moderation des User-Generated-Content gedacht.
Wir können uns jetzt hinsetzen und können überlegen,
oh mein Gott, wie lösen wir das Problem bei 100.000 Anrufen pro Tag
oder bei 50.000 Inseraten pro Tag.
Und oh mein Gott, das können wir gar nicht.
Das geht nur mit Watson.
Das geht nur mit, keine Ahnung,
2 Millionen Venture Capital Finanzierung
und einem Team von 50 Leuten.
Oder man definiert einfach,
nee, wir bleiben eine kleine Plattform
und machen es einfach per Hand.
Genau, oder wir machen es einfach mal
und fangen einfach an
und machen das in Handarbeit
und in dem Moment,
in dem wir wirklich dann an den Punkt kommen,
an dem wir es nicht mehr handeln können,
müssen wir entweder dann Features abschalten
oder uns was Besseres überlegen.
Aber ich finde das großartig.
Das ist einfach super pragmatisch.
Und auf die Art und Weise habt ihr sehr schnell
einen Fuß in die Tür gekriegt.
Und die Plattform läuft ja heute immer noch.
Und offenbar seid ihr noch nicht alle am Burnout zum Opfer gefallen.
Oder wie ist das so?
Du hast gesagt, ihr seid ein Team von 20 Leuten.
Und ihr habt auch quasi Hotline-Dienst und da klingelt ab und zu mal das Telefon.
Und ihr habt einen Slack-Channel, wo jede einzelne Anfrage erst mal landet.
Und ihr entscheidet dann händisch durch Lesen und Nachdenken, dass die freigeschaltet werden darf.
Und ihr seid ein Verein von Freiwilligen, die das alles nebenbei machen.
Wie gut funktioniert das noch?
Momentan funktioniert das noch sehr gut. Unser Team ist mittlerweile ein bisschen geschrumpft. Also das ganz große Team, das in der Hochzeit auch des medialen Ansturms auf die Plattform da war, das komplette Team ist dann nicht zum Gründungsmitglied des Vereins geworden.
Den Verein haben wir mit ein paar weniger Mitgliedern dann gegründet. Aktiv Leute, die sich auch jede Woche noch treffen, an der Plattform arbeiten, auch den Hotline-Dienst übernehmen, sind wir auch mittlerweile ein paar weniger, weil natürlich das Leben weiterging und viele Leute dann auch gesagt haben, es tut mir leid, ich habe einfach auch jetzt nicht mehr so viel Zeit.
Und wir da auch immer offen waren, weil wir ja selber auch wissen, im Ehrenamt ist es häufig so, dass Menschen sich überbelasten und sich zu viel zumuten und deswegen war es für uns auch immer wichtig, dass man sagen kann, hey, mir wächst das über den Kopf, es tut mir leid, ich unterstütze euch gerne noch, wo ich kann, aber ich muss mich jetzt hier mal ein bisschen rausnehmen.
Momentan wird es wieder ein bisschen mehr, was den Workload angeht, auch täglich so im Operations-Bereich.
Die Hotline klingelt jetzt mittlerweile deutlich häufiger, weil auch einige Gesundheitsämter damit begonnen haben, unsere Telefonnummer rauszugeben.
Voll gut.
Ich vermute im Kontext, eine Person bekommt den Anruf, sie wurden positiv getestet, bitte begeben sie sich in Quarantäne und wenn sie Hilfe benutzen, dann gibt es hier die Quarantäne-Heldin, ruft doch gerne mal da an.
Das führt auch manchmal zu ein bisschen Verwirrung, weil den Menschen, die dann direkt quasi bei uns anrufen, so ein bisschen die Überleitung zu dem Zweck fehlt.
die haben gesagt, wir sollen mal anrufen,
deswegen erfüllen möchten.
Genau, die haben gesagt, wir sollen da anrufen
und die haben gesagt, bei euch gibt es was zu essen.
Ist ja auch gut, wie wir da unternehmen.
Also manchmal müssen wir dann
manchmal müssen wir dann auch erstmal
ein bisschen Expectations managen,
um dann zu schauen,
wobei wir
gern unterstützen und unterstützen können.
Wo es ja dann wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen enttäuscht ist,
wenn man dann sagen muss, ja, Moment,
sie haben sich da so richtig,
Also wir helfen Ihnen gerne, aber erwarten Sie mal nicht zu viel oder so.
Das müsste Sie wahrscheinlich...
Ja, natürlich. Manchmal ist das auch traurig.
Also vor allem haben wir manchmal auch ältere Leute, die bei uns anrufen und von Einsamkeit geplagt sind.
Und einfach auch jemanden mal zum Reden suchen.
Und wir hatten schon auch an der Hotline lange, lange emotionale, rührende Gespräche mit Menschen, die uns dann von ihrer Geschichte erzählt haben.
Und das sind dann auch Punkte, bei denen wir dann vermitteln können. Es gibt dann auch andere tolle Organisationen wie das Silbernetz zum Beispiel.
Wer?
Zu denen wir auch kontaktieren. Das Silbernetz. Das ist eine Organisation, die sich eben dem Problem von Einsamkeit im Alter gewidmet hat.
und die über eine, ich glaube, auch eine ausgeklügelte Software dann Telefon,
ich will nicht sagen Telefonketten, aber so Telefonfreundschaften etablieren
und dort Menschen, die gerne mal ein bisschen quatschen wollen,
sozusagen jemanden finden können, der genauso Bock hat mal zu quatschen
und sich dann...
An dieser Stelle
würde mich jetzt interessieren,
wenn man mal an die Unix-Philosophie
denkt. Unix-Philosophie
heißt, ein Tool löst ein
Problem und das gut. Und
Quarantäne-Helden macht das. Das ist ein schwarzes
Brett oder es ist ein Brett
für Leute, die sich gegenseitig,
wenn sie in Quarantäne
sind, helfen. Und jetzt
hast du gerade angeschnitten, es gibt natürlich noch andere
Probleme, die Leute haben, die dann aber vielleicht bei euch
auftauchen.
Das heißt, habt ihr dann eventuell eine Übersichtsseite für, das sind so Sachen, die häufig bei uns landen, aber dafür gibt es eigentlich bessere Helfer. Geht doch mal hier hin. Habt ihr da schon irgendwie eine feste Liste von Sachen, sowas wie das Silbernetz?
Das gibt es bisher, gibt es für uns nur intern. Also wir haben noch nicht genügend, sage ich mal, solcher problematischen Fälle gesammelt, um zu sagen, wir bauen jetzt vielleicht eine zusätzliche Unterseite oder so.
Es wäre auch vielleicht gar nicht so zielführend, weil die Leute ja eben nicht auf der Website gelandet sind, sondern bei uns auf der Hotline. Deswegen helfen da für uns intern unsere Leitlinien für die Telefonate schon meistens weiter, um den Leuten dann irgendwie zu sagen, hey, schau doch mal dort oder versuch doch mal dort jemanden zu erreichen.
Ist dann natürlich häufig auch schwierig, weil Organisationen wie Gesundheitsämter oder das Rote Kreuz oder Seelsorge natürlich auch überlaufen sind und man dann dort häufig niemanden erreicht oder nur schwierig Leute erreicht.
Aber ja, da können wir dann in dem Moment auch leider nur begrenzt weiterhelfen.
Ja, ihr seid ja auch nur, Quarantäne ist ja quasi auch nur für ein Stück Use Case da und nicht um alle Probleme zu lösen.
Aber deswegen würde mich jetzt nochmal ein Punkt interessieren.
Und zwar ist es ja trotzdem ein öffentlicher Dienst, den ihr anbietet.
Es war ein Haufen Freiwillige, die das gerne machen.
Aber man könnte sich ja genauso gut vorstellen, so eine Plattform, wo sich die Leute gerade in so einer Situation helfen, ist ja vielleicht auch was, was nicht unbedingt die Leute selbst machen sollten.
Man könnte sich vielleicht auch vorstellen, das könnte auch eine staatliche Aufgabe sein.
Also sowas wie Quarantäreheldinnen.org könnte genauso gut von der Bundesregierung oder von der sächsischen Regierung oder von der Stadt organisiert werden.
Das hat dann immer ein bisschen vielleicht noch das Problem, dass es dann eine bürokratische Hölle wird oder dass es vielleicht zu lokal ist, wenn es bloß, keine Ahnung, Dresden aufzieht.
Und dann auf dresden.de könnte man sich vorstellen, dass diese Städte selber auf so eine Idee kommen, so eine Unterseite für genau solche Sachen zu machen.
Aber dann, du hast gerade das Rote Kreuz erwähnt, es gibt auch natürlich auch andere karitative Organisationen, die vielleicht auch genau solche Probleme mitlösen können, wollen und auch bereits eine längere Tradition und mehr Infrastruktur haben.
Habt ihr mal überlegt, ob das vielleicht was wäre, dass ihr euch mit sowas wie dem Roten Kreuz oder ähnlichen Organisationen einfach zusammenschließt und sagt, guck mal, wir brauchen Leute, die eine Hotline betreuen oder Leute, die, ihr habt doch da, ihr habt doch da, ich will jetzt nicht sagen Manpower, aber ihr habt doch da Menschen, die eventuell mithelfen könnten. Ist das was, was bei euch mal diskutiert wurde?
Also in den vergangenen Monaten haben wir immer mal wieder über verschiedene mögliche Kooperationen intern gesprochen. Es kam jetzt noch nicht, das waren damals eigentlich immer vor allem so technische Kooperationen.
Ich hatte ja schon darüber gesprochen, dass es auch irgendwie andere Plattformen gab, die ähnliche Sachen anbieten wollten.
Wir haben eigentlich immer dann häufig schnell versucht, irgendwie in Kontakt zu treten und dann zu schauen, kann man da irgendwie gemeinsam was machen.
Das hat leider in den seltensten Fällen gut funktioniert.
Unser Outreach in Richtung anderer größerer etablierter Organisationen war bisher auch, so viel ich weiß, recht begrenzt, weil einerseits niemand auf uns zukam und aktiv nach unserer Hilfe gefragt hat oder geschaut hat, wollen wir da was zusammen machen.
Als wir mal versuchten, mit Städten und Gemeinden in Kontakt zu treten, wurde uns dann häufig leider gesagt, es tut mir leid, wir können eure Info nicht auf unserer Website nehmen oder sowas, weil ihr seid ein Verein und ihr seid nichts Offizielles und das können wir nicht machen.
Umso lustiger war es dann, als dann in den gleichen Kommunen dann irgendwann die Gesundheitsämter angefangen haben, unsere Telefonnummer rauszugeben. Also da war viele, viele Sachen waren da eben irgendwie schwierig und meist unklar, dass wir auch von offizieller Seite so ein bisschen irgendwie Anerkennung bekommen haben.
Das war eigentlich für uns dann nachvollziehbar, als die Bundesregierung uns auf die Seite zusammen gegen Corona genommen hat und auch dort als Nachbarschaftshilfe-Plattform genannt hat und wir in diesem kleinen Werbespot da vorgekommen sind.
Aber leider war dann auch dort die offizielle Zusammenarbeit beendet und es ging nicht darüber hinaus. Das war ein bisschen schade, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass das an vielen Stellen oder dass viele Projekte da ähnliche Probleme hatten.
Also ich kenne da zum Beispiel noch von einem Bekannten ein Projekt, die wollten den Nachverfolgungsworkflow in Gesundheitsämtern digital unterstützen.
Ach, davon habe ich auch gehört, ja.
Weil wir ja alle mitbekommen haben, dass diese Kontaktnachverfolgung da häufig auf Basis von Telefon- und Excel-Listen...
Da gab es Leute, die an der App extra dafür gearbeitet haben.
Genau und ich hörte dann auch davon, dass es sehr schwierig sei, Gesundheitsämter oder offizielle Stellen dazu zu bewegen, diese Dinge dann auch wirklich einzusetzen, weil die Herausforderungen dort auch ganz andere sind, die man jetzt dann vermutlich auch selber gar nicht auf dem Schirm hat und so eine Pandemie dann auch nicht der Moment ist, um jetzt mal was Neues einzuführen und auszuprobieren.
Wann, wenn nicht dann? Aber du hast schon
recht, so wie es die Bundeskanzlerin sagen würde,
Corona ist für uns alle Neuland.
Ja,
also wenn das Internet schon Neuland ist, dann war
Corona erst recht Neuland.
Weißt du, was ist der Name von dieser App noch?
Bloß so für die
Nachwelt?
Müssen wir
nochmal raussuchen. Also ich weiß, dass ich auch irgendwie,
die hatten ein relativ gutes, die hatten sogar ein recht
gut gemachtes Promo-Video gemacht.
Aber mir fällt leider auch nicht mehr ein,
wie die hießen.
Ich meine, es gab ja da auch den großen Hackathon, aus dem einiges rausgefallen ist. Und der Hackathon, der hat ja auch dann, also da hat ja die Bundesregierung auch ein bisschen Geld in die Hand genommen, um dann nach dem Hackathon bestimmte Projekte, die da auserkoren wurden, als förderungsfähig dann auch noch mit weiterer finanzieller Unterstützung versorgt.
Ich habe allerdings ein bisschen den Überblick verloren, welche Dinge da wirklich nachhaltig dann entstanden sind.
Aus dem Hackathon?
Aus dem Hackathon heraus, ja. Wir durften damals leider nicht.
Das wäre meine Frage gewesen, weil?
Als Projekt.
Das ist mir bis zum heutigen Tag gar nicht so richtig klar.
So wie ich das verstanden habe, war damals die Aussage, unsere Plattform existiere bereits und sei bereits am Markt und im Hackathon wolle man nur Projekte unterstützen, die jetzt quasi so initial starten.
Aber das war meine persönliche Interpretation.
Es ist jetzt auch schon ganz lange her.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz im Klaren,
was da der genaue Wortlaut war.
Wir durften aber leider damals nicht als offizielles Projekt
da teilnehmen.
Das war ein bisschen schade.
Wir waren zu früh.
Aus diesen Hackathons sind ja so ein paar Sachen rausgekommen,
die eigentlich ganz cool waren.
Also die prinzipiell grundlegende Funktionsweise der Corona-Warn-App
ist ja auch bei einem der allerersten Hackathons
so ein bisschen geprototyped worden.
Andere Projekte,
die ich jetzt gesehen habe, waren, dass man
eine App baut, die
dieses
Kontaktdaten hinterlassen an unterschiedlichen
Stellen, wie im Kino oder im Restaurant,
irgendwie ersetzt durch, ich scanne einen QR-Code
ab oder ich habe einen, der
abgescannt wird, damit ich
kontaktierbar bin, ohne meinen
persönlichen Nachnamen mit Adresse und
Telefonnummer unbedingt bei jedem Restaurant
lassen zu müssen. Fand ich auch gut,
weil dann haltet vielleicht die Leute davon ab,
sich überall als Darth Vader einzutragen oder Donald Duck oder so.
Aber ja.
Habt ihr sonst noch andere technische Sachen,
die ihr als nächstes bauen wollt, wo wir gerade beim Hackathon waren?
Was ihr für eure Plattformen so als technische Verbesserung
oder nächste Iteration machen wollt?
Ich hab noch eine Frage, die ich nämlich noch eine Weile
schon hier stehen habe.
www.kipro
und das mir direkt ins Auge gefallen ist,
war das einfacheres Löschen von Subscriptions
für Notifications,
wenn man Notifications nicht mehr bekommt.
Der Unsubscribe-Link in der E-Mail quasi.
Der Unsubscribe-Link.
Wir sehen gerade noch Möglichkeiten der Verbesserung
in der User Experience des Prozesses.
Ich suche Hilfe oder ich brauche Hilfe.
Das ist natürlich noch so ein bisschen rough.
Und da könnten wir auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen mehr leiten,
noch ein bisschen besser die Leute an die Hand nehmen,
auch selber noch ein bisschen aktiver kommunizieren,
damit wir auch ein besseres Bild dafür bekommen,
wie ist hier gerade der Stand.
Aber für uns ist das immer so ein bisschen ein Trade-off,
weil wir wollen natürlich einerseits,
wir wollen ja nicht so zu einer App werden,
die dann irgendwie eine Notification schickt.
Hey, du hast vor einer Woche das letzte Mal in dein Inserat geschaut.
Ist das denn noch aktuell?
Möchtest du nicht vielleicht irgendwie hier mal was Neues schreiben oder so?
Das wollen wir ja auch nicht,
weil wir die Leute irgendwie nicht nerven wollen
und weil man dann auch wieder mehr Daten...
Aber ein bisschen User Experience ist da schon wichtig.
Ja, das ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig,
da den Sweet Spot zu finden.
Und da tänzeln wir immer so ein bisschen drumherum
und da arbeiten wir auch noch dran.
Also wir haben da schon häufiger drüber nachgedacht, weil wir uns natürlich auch immer, wir hätten natürlich am liebsten diese Liste 1200 Anfragen alle markiert als gelöst.
Aber wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwie sagen, das Feature als gelöst markieren, ist vor zwei Wochen rausgekommen, an alle Inserate davor schicken wir jetzt nochmal eine E-Mail, ist das eigentlich gelöst worden, dann steckt, also es ist halt auch doof, dann nerven wir die Leute, dann stecken wir in der nächsten Spamliste drin und dann kommen unsere Notifications gar nicht mehr an.
Obwohl man ja wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen kann, dass wenn so eine Anfrage zwei Wochen alt ist, dann ist die vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr aktuell.
Häufig, ja. Wir hatten auch
schon Antworten auf
Anfragen nach neun Monaten.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Aber ich glaube,
tatsächlich war da, weil es die Anfrage noch
aktuell, da ging es nämlich um,
ging es ja auch um Haustiere?
Oder um?
Also auf jeden Fall war das damals, glaube ich, noch aktuell.
Der Arm ist seit neun Monaten nicht Gassi gegangen.
Der ist Detailverstopp.
Long Covid.
Oh Mann.
Ein bisschen dark.
Aber da probieren wir uns gerade noch so ein bisschen aus.
Ja krass, Tom, vielen Dank für diese sehr aufschlussreiche und doch sehr spannende Geschichte.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde dieses Projekt durchaus bemerkenswert und ich finde das super toll, dass ihr dieses Projekt ins Leben gerufen habt und bis heute weiter stemmt.
Auf jeden Fall ist ein echt wertvoller Beitrag
auch für die Allgemeinheit.
Richtig stark.
Genau, also
ihr seid auf
quarantäneheldinnen.org
und auf quarantänehelden.org zu erreichen.
Man kann euch sicherlich auch
kontaktieren,
wenn man zum Beispiel
bei der Hotline mit aushelfen möchte.
Ist das was, wo ihr Interesse dran habt?
Wenn sich Leute...
Klar, gern.
Wer in jeglicher Hinsicht Lust hat,
mehr über die Organisation
zu erfahren, auch vielleicht mehr über
option26.org.
Meldet euch gerne, wir freuen uns
immer über Feedback, auch wenn euch irgendwas
auffällt bei der Website, was man noch verbessern
könnte.
Sehr gerne.
Sehr cool. Macht option26
außer Quarantäne-Heldin noch
bereits andere Projekte?
Nee.
Noch nicht.
Ja.
Ah, okay.
Der Slack-Channel will die Ideen,
der sprüht,
zwar voller Kreativität,
aber bisher hat sich
da noch nichts.
Ist ja auch vielleicht was Gutes, wenn ihr euch
wirklich auf Quarantänehelden.org
konzentrieren könnt
und nicht Startup-mäßig
fünf Töpfe gleichzeitig auf dem Feuer habt
oder sowas.
Weil so ein Projekt wie Quarantänehelden
kann ja durchaus konsistent
ein bisschen Liebe erfahren und dann funktioniert das auch
besser, als wenn das bloß so nebenbei gemacht wird.
Also ich finde das auch super, dass ihr tatsächlich
eine Hotline betreibt, dass das
funktioniert und genutzt wird. Sehr schön.
Gut.
Ja, vielen Dank zu diesem Thema.
So, bei Akronomisierbar haben wir
normalerweise an dieser Stelle,
ihr könnt ja wieder ein bisschen
aus dem konkreten Thema rauskommen,
wir haben eine Sektion Picks
und da haben wir dich gebeten, vielleicht auch
ein paar Sachen zu erwähnen. Vielleicht
irgendwas aus dem Kontext
von
Quarantänehelden?
Also den einzigen Pick,
den ich tatsächlich
vorbereitet habe im Corona-Kontext
ist eine Podcast-Empfehlung.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das
Es darf kein Podcast
neben akronomisierbar gehört werden.
Das ist doch so schade.
Aber dabei sagst du doch immer
und jetzt kommt der nächste Podcast
in eurer Playlist in 321.
Ja, das ist doch hoffentlich die nächste Folge.
Die 47.
Nee, und zwar?
Und zwar
Corona Weekly
von Unsere kleine Welt.
Der Tim Prittloff aus der Metaebene
und der Pavel, glaube ich,
zusammen, die haben
mich vor allem in den letzten Monaten
da super gut informiert
durch diese ganze Pandemie
gebracht, weil sie sich
häufig,
wenn es ganz akut wird, wöchentlich
und manchmal ein bisschen in loserem
Zeitabstand
sich die Zahlen
genau anschauen, auch die Zahlen in Deutschland
und weltweit anschauen
und ein bisschen genauer
analysieren,
welche Effekte dort zu sehen sind,
was, wann und woher
jetzt vielleicht kommt, wie das alles
zu interpretieren ist, weil wir ja
auch, wenn man so ein bisschen
nerdig da drauf geschaut hat, in den
vergangenen Monaten ja auch gesehen hat,
irgendwie bestimmte Metriken
oder Parameter oder sei es
nur die Datenlage
offiziell, die dann das RKI
oder verschiedene Landkreise
irgendwie rausgeben, dass das
manchmal ein großes Durcheinander ist
und es da
durchaus hilfreich sein kann, wenn
sich jemand da mal konsistent damit
beschäftigt und da ein bisschen
abstrakteren, vorgefilterten
Blick drauf. Es ist gut, wenn man das ein bisschen interpretiert
bekommt, das stimmt. Es gibt ja auch unterschiedliche
Datenquellen, die man dann falsch
interpretieren kann.
Oder warum gibt es Unterschiede
zwischen Datenquellen? Es gibt so die
eine, keine Ahnung,
die eine Zahl ist immer höher als die andere, oder
dort wird der R-Wert immer anders angegeben.
Wie kommt das überhaupt?
Und da haben die beiden auf jeden Fall
mir zumindest in den letzten Monaten da
immer gute Infos gegeben. Also ukw.fm
Das ist auch generell immer noch ein cooler Podcast-Titel,
UKW.fm.
Perfekt.
Hört ihr noch den
Drosten-Podcast?
Mittlerweile ist ja da noch jemand anders
mit dazugekommen. Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Bitte?
Habe ich noch nie gehört, muss ich ehrlich
zugeben. Ich höre mit meiner Podcast-QE
im März immer noch fest, also
ich komme da gar nicht hinterher.
Du darfst ja keine Folge
auslassen von irgendwas.
Nee, ich versuche,
habe mittlerweile schon getan, aber
im März stimmt es nicht mehr, aber ich glaube,
im Juni bin ich tatsächlich noch.
Also ich habe den
auch schon Weichen jetzt nicht mehr gehört, aber
der ist tatsächlich auch sehr empfehlenswert.
Kann man durchaus abonniert haben.
Vom NDR,
der Corona-Podcast,
Corona-Update heißt der, glaube ich.
Ich packe mal einen Link in die Show Notes dazu.
Es hilft ja auch einfach, wenn man sich mit der
Krise wirklich
dass man sich einfach informieren lässt und nicht,
niemand ist da wirklich hinterher und
sich die wirklich relevanten
Infos überall zusammenzusuchen und es ist
sehr angenehm, wenn andere Leute das
übernehmen, die auch wirklich kompetent sind, wie
Christian Drosten.
Genau.
Ja, was ich als
Pick hätte, es gibt ja
diverse
Coronavirus-Webseiten,
die Karten
anbieten, wo man
Zahlen sieht. Eines, was jetzt
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir es im Podcast schon mal erwähnt haben, aber was ich ganz gut finde für Dresden ist coronavirusdresden.de vom Diego. Es ist einfach bloß so ein Grafana-Board, wo die Daten für Dresden nochmal explizit visualisiert werden.
Finde ich sehr gut. Auch so Seiten wie Risk Layer, wo visualisiert wird, was in welchem Landkreis gerade für Zahlen oder für Inzidenzwerte herrschen. Das sind allerdings alle Seiten, die Angst machen. Da guckst du hin und denkst dir so, das ist quasi Doomscrolling auf Datenbasis.
und wir reden ja immer
wir reden ja auch immer über Corona, wenn wir uns unterhalten
immer so, es hat so ein bisschen
den Wetterbericht verdrängt
nur, dass es im Gegensatz zum
Wetterbericht, was
Pandemielager angeht, eigentlich immer nur schlechte Nachrichten
gibt, es gibt selten
es gibt selten wirklich gute Nachrichten
beim
Wetterbericht regnet es, aber
da scheint auch manchmal die Sonne
und das fehlte irgendwie so ein bisschen bei der Pandemie, dafür finde ich es schön
dass wir ab und zu mal sowas wie
Quarantänehelden.org erwähnen dürfen.
Aber was jetzt zum Beispiel, was ich jetzt neu gefunden habe,
was ich als Pick erwähnen möchte,
ist von der Zeit, ist bestimmt nicht die einzige Seite,
es gibt auch von anderen Nachrichtenanbietern
so Karten, aber es gibt,
ich finde die von der Zeit mit am
übersichtlichsten, eine
Visualisierung der verabreichten
Impfdosen
deutschlandweit. Wo ich auch so ein bisschen
stolz bin, dass Sachsen-Anhalt da
relativ weit
vorne ist im Bereich und ein bisschen
ein bisschen schockiert bin, wie schlecht
Sachsen da dasteht. Das ist tatsächlich irgendwie
doppelt so viele Leute im Verhältnis
geimpft in Sachsen-Anhalt wie in Sachsen.
Sehr feinlich. Aber ich pack mal mit in die
Shownotes die Seite von
der Zeit mit der Impfkarte.
Das ist definitiv schön, wenn man mal
wachsenden Zahlen zuschauen kann, die
nicht das genaue Gegenteil bedeuten
von irgendwelchen Infektions- oder
Todeszahlen, sondern wie viele
Leute geimpft sind. Mittlerweile ist es echt
schön, wie rapid es da auch hochgeht.
Natürlich muss es noch ein bisschen schneller werden, sonst
das gerade mal in zehn Jahren das Land durch zu impfen,
aber das wird schon.
Ja, da kann man tatsächlich noch ein bisschen das Tempo
annehmen. Also ich habe
irgendwie gehört, am Anfang war geplant, dass man
700.000 Leute pro Woche impfen wollte
und das klingt erstmal viel.
Dann rechnet man aus, dass es dann zwei Jahre dauert,
die gesamte deutsche Bevölkerung zu impfen.
Wir sind schon echt viele.
Und momentan schaffen wir es nicht mal,
700.000 Leute pro Woche zu impfen.
Also wir haben jetzt
laut der Zeitkarte haben wir
jetzt, und ich glaube, wir machen das schon seit über
haben wir gerade mal 500.000 Leute, 500.000 Impfdosen verabreicht.
Und das sind immer noch nicht, das heißt, die Leute sind alle nur halb geimpft.
Die müssen nämlich ja nach drei Wochen nochmal geimpft werden.
Das kommt noch dazu.
Aber ich glaube, die Impfzentren sind auch noch nicht alle wirklich voll funktional,
beziehungsweise da kommt noch einiges hinzu.
Also das ist noch im Aufbau.
Gerade wirklich im Gesamtbund.
Also in manchen Bundesländern läuft das schon viel effizienter.
Gerade Sachsen und ich glaube, Thüringen war auch so ein Schlusslicht,
zumindest was die Absolutzahlen angeht.
Das ist noch ein bisschen hinterher.
Auf jeden Fall. Ja, also das war mein Pick. Schaut euch diese Impfkarten an. Also wenn ihr nicht gerade denkt, dass ihr da gechippt werdet, dann gebt einem diese Impfkarte doch ein etwas positiveres Gefühl.
Und ich denke, da sind schon ein paar Leute sicherer.
Also ich sehe gerade bei der Zeitkarte ja auch,
dass die Quelle auch hier das Robert-Koch-Institut ist.
Da hofft man ja, dass dieser Datensatz irgendwie auch offen zu erreichen ist.
Und das heißt, es wird in den kommenden Wochen
bestimmt noch viel spannendere und tollere Impf-Zivilisierungen geben.
Ja, das ist immer, ich glaube, ein Kritikpunkt an den Daten
des Robert-Koch-Instituts war,
dass die keine rückwirkenden Daten zur Verfügung stellen.
Also das gibt immer den aktuellen Datensatz
und der wird dann einfach überschrieben.
Du kannst dir nicht die Daten von letzter Woche angucken.
Und das macht es schwierig, gerade so Trends zu visualisieren.
Deswegen gibt es dann auch Leute,
die das vor der Depublikation retten und regelmäßig runterladen.
Ich glaube, die Seite vom Diego hier,
coronavirusdresden.de, ist auch aus diesem Grund entstanden.
Es gab irgendwie so eine Visualisierung auf dresden.de.
da konnte man keine Trends ablesen,
weil die immer bloß die aktuellen Werte dargestellt hat.
Das vergisst man immer mal. Das war auch damals
beim Open Data
Stammtisch
Meetup hier in Dresden. Da war die
Stadt hat mal so ein schönes neues Portal veröffentlicht,
wo sie viele Daten hatten und haben auch
gefragt, natürlich hier
Leute konsultiert, was halten die davon? Wie schaut
das aus? Wie sind die Datensätze so?
Und eins der Feedback-Stücke,
die mit angesprochen wurden, waren, wie schaut das
aus mit demselben Datensatz, wenn der hier immer wieder
überschrieben wird mit historischem Kontext,
oh stimmt, sowas könnten
wir ja auch machen.
So ein Kontext kann manchmal echt hilfreich sein,
aber vielleicht, wenn man da gar nicht dran denkt,
ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass das RKI nicht daran gedacht hat,
sondern da das Aktuelle das
Wichtigste für die war, aber das gibt immerhin
schon einen schönen Kontext mit.
Ich glaube, zum RKI gibt es noch dazu,
dass die, was IT angeht,
wirklich unterbesetzt sind.
Ja, die haben jetzt vier neue Stellen.
Wow.
Da war irgend sowas, ja, da gibt es irgendwie
da gibt es irgendwie fünf Leute und jetzt haben sie endlich
vier neue Leute angestellt, aber die müssen auch gleichzeitig
für das gesamte Robert-Koch-Institut irgendwie
die Windows-Version patchen oder
aktualisieren, die Computer betreuen.
Die machen nicht nur das bisschen Datenaushang
Schild, das ist schon eine Leistung, sondern die machen
wirklich alles.
Oh Gott, okay. Aber wenn wir gerade schon bei
Visualisierungen waren, ein Pick, den ich mit
auf die Liste packen wollte, aber der blöderweise schon da stand,
da klaue ich dir den einfach, Hendrik.
Klau mir den ruhig.
Das ist für die iOS-Nutzer unter euch.
Es gab vor einer ganzen Zeit schon mal so ein schönes
über die großartige App Scriptable,
dass man sich auf den Homescreen legen konnte,
wo einfach die aktuelle Inzidenzzahl mit da war für den aktuellen Standort.
Das wurde beim Laufen des Widgets automatisch geschaut, wo ist man gerade.
Das wurde aufgelöst und dementsprechend die Inzidenzzahl angezeigt,
in meinem Fall für Dresden.
Und das wurde jetzt noch ein bisschen aufgebohrt,
beziehungsweise schon wieder ein bisschen her,
dass es nicht nur das anzeigt,
sondern auch noch mit kleinen Graphen und Entwicklungen
für das Bundesland oder komplett Deutschland
und jetzt auch noch sehr cool mit der aktuellen
Impfzahl mit drauf und da kann man gleich auf dem
Homescreen mit im Auge behalten, wie viele
Leute denn in Sachsen mittlerweile geimpft sind.
Das finde ich echt sehr anwendig. Ach, das ist auch
schon mit drin? Das muss man zwar
aktuell im JavaScript-Soft
noch existieren, da ist ein ganz oben ein Flag mit
Show-Vaccine-Account
oder irgendwas. Muss man noch
enablen, aber danach sieht man das auch gleich mit drin.
Das ist sehr toll. Aktuell sind es knapp
60, nee, gerade aktualisiert von
16 auf 18.000 Leute hoch. Schön.
3000 Euro irgendwo verteilt.
In Sachsen.
Na, immerhin. Immerhin.
Ja, schön. Sehr geil. Vielen Dank.
Ich glaube, an dieser Stelle können wir
jetzt auch den Abschluss finden. Es war eine sehr
leider wieder eine sehr coronalastige, aber
ich möchte doch behaupten, eine sehr positive
Sendung. Vielen Dank,
Tom, dass du da warst und uns
alles über Corona-Helden
Quatsch.
über Quarantänehelden
erzählt hast.
Wir verlinken eure Kontaktdaten
definitiv hier. Und für alle Leute,
die noch mehr Fragen an euch haben,
ihr könnt euch direkt an Tom wenden
oder die Kontaktdaten zu
quarantänehelden.org, die wir euch hier in den
Show Notes miterwähnen oder die einfach auf
quarantänehelden.org
zu finden sind.
Auf jeden Fall, hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Danke fürs dabei sein.
Genau, und dadurch, da du
Hörer unseres Podcasts bist
und weißt, wie wir die Sendung beenden,
überlassen wir dir diesmal die Ehre, den
Countdown zu starten.
Oder
Meta, wollen wir noch ein anderes Thema
ansprechen? Gibt es noch irgendwas, was wir...
Nee, ich glaube, das ist
ein guter Abschluss, ja.
Ja, ist ein guter Abschluss, gut.
Okay, dann bitte.
Okay, jetzt nochmal ein bisschen Aufregung
zum Schluss. Ich hoffe, ich mache das richtig.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr zugehört habt.
Der nächste Podcast in eurer Playlist kommt in 3, 2, 1.